thank you
[Applause]
good morning Dr Goodall for attack good
morning
could we commence please with
the issue of the Welsh government's
corporate risk register what are
risk registers
so I would say that we have two
different risk registers which are
associated in this area we would have a
national risk register which would be in
the arena of our hazards and threats on
our emergency planning and preparedness
and there would be a route for reviewing
those we would we also have our
corporate risk registers in the
organization which tend to capture a
much broader range of
risk areas issues which have to be
addressed by the organization so that
can include matters of Workforce matters
of delivering government policy but the
running of the organization so I would
say there's a difference between those
two approaches but we use both
the first one the national risk register
the inquiries heard evidence that
in the main from cabinet office
Witnesses in Whitehall
concerned with the
production and maintenance of a United
Kingdom risk register
which sets out a number of risks that I
think there are over 100 now in fact in
the nsra the latest variant of the
national risk register and the inquiry
has also had evidence from
Scottish Witnesses in relation to the
maintenance of a Scottish risk
assessment process
is there a
analog
for Wales in terms of the risk register
so we use the the national risk register
and that would be consistent with the
advice that you've had from Kadler
office colleagues there are risk
registers which are used at the local
resilience Forum level and they are part
of those local and Regional Arrangements
there is no intermediate Wales hazards
and threats risk register which draws
those together the wells risk Wells
resilience Forum will oversee those
arrangements but we try to allow that to
be focused at the local resilience for a
level deliberately with our four Forum
in Wales
there are risk assessments and risk
assessment plans at the local resilience
Forum level indeed yes in the same way
that there are risk assessment plans
at the local resilience Forum level in
England there happen to be more local
residents forums in England than there
are in Wales or any four in Wales but
but that is the local risk assessment
process yes focusing on the national
level
risks which present themselves to the
United Kingdom and England are not
necessarily the same risks
that may present themselves to whales
because you you might have a particular
form of threat or hazard
in in Wales I don't know particular form
of flooding or a particular locality
which might be flooded
and therefore a different risk to that
which
May develop in relation to parts of
England or the United Kingdom generally
yes I would agree the the broad range of
risks and threats would be consistent
but of course there would be some
geographical differences in the Wales
context and I think because we only had
we only have four local resilience for
her
um we didn't feel that we needed to
really work those through although the
world's resilience Forum does have a
program of work that will highlight
those risks that emerge but I would
agree with you that where we are now
um you know we are introducing a Wells
risk register and it's for the very
points that you say that irrespective of
Health areas and preparedness there are
some more unique issues for example
cultip safety in Wales and some of the
you know natural resource issues as well
I can't recall when Scotland introduced
its own Scottish risk assessment process
but but on the on the premise that it
was some time ago um
has the Welsh government
specifically considered the merits of a
Welsh risk assessment process over the
10 or so years
from the inauguration of the risk
assessment process in Whitehall which I
think was 2010. I think certainly with
the transfer of responsibilities in 2018
I think that was in our thinking to look
to convert it but in some respects we
were not looking to at that point
duplicate some of those uk-wide areas
because it felt that they were providing
the appropriate backdrop to the hazards
and threats that we were facing at that
time
um in terms of our current thinking and
indeed reflecting on our own lessons and
actions that we've adapted that is
absolutely part of our thinking now that
we do need to represent it in that way
so there is a Wales risk register in
respect of those hazards and threats
under review at this moment by the
current resilience team you refer to
thinking is there any guidance or or
paperwork to which may we may refer
ourselves where where this issue has
been specifically considered by the
Welsh government I would have expected
that as we absorb those responsibilities
in 2018 it would have formed a pattern
of work to review not because that was
being pressed at that time but the
reality was in 2018 our resilience
attention had just switched and we
weren't able really to discharge some of
those early expectations from sector
Assurance plans so there is no
documentation as such but I know there
have been some thinking over that
previous time relying on actually the
individual risk assessments that came up
from the local resilience for and I said
that was translated in document style
into the program of work for the world's
resilience forum
I'm sorry to press you you said there
was a pattern of work and thinking was
done in a document Style
was a document drawn up in which the
issue of creating a Welsh risk
assessment was debated no I'm just
reflecting that there was no document at
that time right
in hindsight and and it must surely
follow because
the Welsh governance position now is
that there is a need for a Welsh Centric
risk assessment process
that that was an error it should really
have been done at the time that the
transfer of functions order was made in
2018 so that there would be a risk
assessment structure
to which these new executive functions
from Whitehall
could be attached yes it helps the
clarity of the functions and
responsibilities that moved across and
that helps to clarify a change from
support and de facto leadership
Arrangements into the coordination role
so yes I would agree and as I said you
know our current thinking and experience
and activities that are taking place are
are actually looking to produce an
intermediate Wales risk register that
reflects our own priorities in Wales
now used uh ifme respectfully suggests
another euphemism you're looking
to produce has
the process started of writing a risk
assessment process for Wales the
resilience team is reviewing Hannah's
instigated arrangements to look at a
whale's risk register
has the decision been made to produce a
Welsh risk assessment
process and register those arrangements
haven't been endorsed by ministers but
the resilience team have actually been
producing a Wales risk register as one
of our lessons learned
has that team
made a decision on a piece of paper
saying the time has come to seek
ministerial approval for the creation of
a risk assessment process for Wales the
team has not done that in line with your
wording so no
so that's the first part the national
risk assessment process the second part
to Gmail references is the corporate
risk register indeed is that process in
existence because the government the
Welsh government like
commercial entities and then another
government bodies
is required to assess
what risks May face that particular
entity the Welsh government and obliged
to identify the steps that are required
to mitigate the risk to ensure that the
consequences that would normally flow
from that risk
developing
be addressed yes in respect of Welsh
government as an organization and in
respect of capturing the risks and
issues that the organization is facing
itself yes
could we have please one two eight nine
six eight
is this the corporate risk register for
the Welsh government in July 2014. uh
yes it is
if we could go to page five and row
P5
thank you
for page six actually
P5 says resilience major emergencies
if we fail to provide leadership to
ensure Wales is prepared for and
resilient to the full range of national
hazards and threats including pandemic
influenza
terrorism major flooding severe weather
and currently the impact of the
firefighters industrial action then
there is a risk to the health and
well-being
[Applause]
of cities the citizens of Wales and then
if we could go back up to Page Six
and the bottom half
the document sets out
does it not
mitigating steps so things that need to
be done in order to make sure that that
risk
doesn't develop into reality and the
controls are
comprehensive governance structure
links with responder agencies liaison
investment in facilities and
Communications emergency contact
Arrangements the existence of a
panwell's response plan ministerial
agreement to
strategies in particular the 2011
document and
Welsh government-led pandemic influenza
group meeting so all I suppose the the
various moving parts of the Welsh
government and what it's doing in
relation to meeting the risk of pandemic
influenza
can you tell from this document Dr
Goodall
what the overall view was of the
state
of those mitigating actions so does the
document tell you what
whether or not the Welsh government
believes that it has adequately
addressed the risk by virtue it's
mitigating actions is there is there a
reasonable nurse or or a a critical
review of the overall state of play in
this document
it sets out the initial assessment of
the risk which is the score of of 20
um that scale runs up to a maximum of 25
and it provides the score on the right
hand side after those actions are being
deployed which allowing for the actions
that are set out under the control
section gives that a school a residual
score of 12. so whilst they don't read
across individually and directly to that
number they would be capturing around a
view that there was a sense of assurance
about the actions that were taking place
at that stage and this would have been
in the run-up to some of the exercise
sickness type arrangements as well at
that time
can you tell from the color coding on
the right hand side the degree of
reasonableness of the actions that were
being taken so is this a a category red
major risk impossible to mitigate or an
orange risk which is that's all right
we've identified reasonable mitigating
steps and we think the risk is now
reduced or is there some sort of other
categorization no it would be your
latter description which you would be
indicating that
and there was a view that those
mitigating steps would have reduced the
overall risk assessment score to what
sort of level to around an Amber level
and what does amber mean Amber means
that
um need to keep it under observation
under consideration it's not at the
highest level of escalation for
fractions all right
can we not move forward please to the
analogous entry for June 2019 just
before the pandemic
21558 please
and if we could scroll into that we may
read it a little more clearly
for quarter one 2019-20
the risk is identified
As A disruption event affecting people
places finances Communications and I.T
if there is a significant disruption
event whether an act of God or planned
attack or event the Welsh government May
struggle to recover its operations
quickly and effectively so that
continuity of business critical
activities is lost
and the mitigating measures are now
identified as the existence of a
business continuity plan in very broad
terms and Disaster Recovery regions are
in place
the assertion that lessons are learned
from disruption events and the claim
that emergency response Protocols are in
place and are practiced through desktop
and live exercises
so a number of questions please Dr
Goodall firstly
why has the identification of the risk
become so much more Broad and opaque by
2019 there is no specific consideration
of pandemic influenza being a risk and
therefore no specific consideration of
what mitigating measures might be
necessary to meet that risk why was that
yeah so like there was a a change in the
development of the corporate risk
register
um
from the earlier version that you showed
as part of the evidence
through to I think it was
2017 2016 2017.
when the risk register had been reviewed
and set out more in the context of the
specific issues that were relevant to
the running and operation of the
organization
and this disruption event description
was translated therefore into could the
organization
reassure that it was able to insulate
its own arrangements so it's an internal
business continuity plans that it was
able to have Disaster Recovery
arrangements for I.T and became more
internally focused in respect of a
smaller range of risks that were set out
in the risk register at the time
from my personal experience because I
was the director general for Health and
Social Services
we had actually included
pandemic flu and other health
emergencies preparedness within the
context of our group-based risk register
and I think rightly whilst of course
that would touch on some of those
internal areas because of our oversight
of the system we actually did need to
make sure that we were covering off
those pandemic flu risks in that Arena
and they were consistently described in
there but there was a shift in the
corporate oversight and the way in which
the risk register was put together so
this is can we set up the emergency
coordinating Center do we have a rotor
in place do we have our own resilience
plans internally and looking at it for
the internal operation of the
organization I'm sorry I don't follow
um wouldn't a corporate risk register
register always focus on the operation
and running of the business with
specific issues relating to it not
following what you mean by changed other
than it obviously did change it it
changed to look at the way in which the
Civil Service itself would step up in
the emergency context and also
recognizing that
emergency planning and response over
time had been limited to individual and
almost rare events we'd seen a pattern
of requiring our contingency
arrangements to kick in much more often
and using our internal coordinating
arrangements so there was a decision
that was taken corporately reflecting on
risk register arrangements and that
decision was maneuvered through it was a
much smaller list of corporate risks
that were held at that level Dr good or
could I asked you as you answer please
to just to slow down a little of course
going very fast for the sonographer of
course
um
Dr Goodall
this is a risk register for the entirety
of the Welsh government is it not it is
the Welsh government corporate risk
register
uh yes yes the Welsh government risk
register for for the operation of the
Civil Service of the organization yes
yes
and risk registers are meant to identify
risks facing the particular body to
which the risk register relates namely
the Welsh government and its
Administration and governance
influenza pandemic was genuinely
generally regarded as the greatest risk
facing the nations of the United Kingdom
it was a tier one risk
in the United Kingdom risk register
so why
if that is if it is or was
the greatest risk facing generically the
Welsh government
was the consideration of that risk the
detail of that risk the proposed
mitigation of the risk the actions
required to meet that risk
downgraded
by virtue of being put into the Health
and Social Services Group risk register
which is not the Welsh government it is
one part of the Welsh government it is
the Health and Social Services part of
the Welsh government
and necessarily then taken out of the
generic corporate risk register
simply at the time the risk register was
developed to
to be more generalized about the
response because of the pattern of
experiences of other events happening
and the need to step up the Wales
resilience arrangements so that was the
decision that was taken at the time in
development
do you accept Dr Goodall that the
inevitable consequence of that decision
was that whilst the civil servants and
ministers in the Health and Social
Services Group part of the Welsh
government
would have been thereafter focusing on
the risk of pandemic influenza because
it was then in their risk register
nobody outside that group would have
been required to focus for the purposes
of the risk register on pandemic flu on
the part of the Welsh government because
it was no longer in the risk register
uh I I don't feel that represents the
position because there was a lot of
preparedness activity taking on
um I know the cabinet received updates
in 2018 and in fact had instigated
sector resilience plans from all of the
sectors in Wales which were explicitly
on pandemic flu and that would have
reflected
seriousness and the high level of risk
associated with it but
there is a danger in looking at the risk
register that whilst it covers a series
of individual areas that you would lose
some other expectation within the
organization
if you weren't able to report up those
concerns from the health group I agree
you make if I may respectfully suggest a
good point which is that of course
work and preparation
continues by the by
but would you agree that if you take out
of a formal
quasi-legal document which is
designed to ensure
that the leaders of the Welsh government
focus on the greatest risks which face
the government as a whole and the people
of Wales
there will inevitably be a tendency to
take awry off the ball because nobody is
saying right what must we do our own
risk register says this is the greatest
threat that we face
or a hazard that we face
we must Focus specifically on what we're
doing to meet it
um I
I'm concerned that it is possible that
organizations would shift their
attention I would hope that the manner
in which we continue to focus on the
hazards and threats
and that risk profile in terms of the
oversight of the world's resilience
Forum would have kept that attention and
certainly we continued with our
preparedness activities through that
period of time
um and of course I had the opportunity
to to raise any additional concerns from
the Health and Social Services Group
perspective because we were overseeing
those arrangements within the detail of
those plans as well where pandemic fluid
did feature
Mr Fawn getting who was
firstly Deputy Minister for health and
then subsequently until the 13th of May
2021 cabinet secretary for health
well-being and Sport
and has provided a
statement to the inquiry in which he
says this
preparedness was not a particular focus
of Interest or concern in government the
senate or outside and I don't remember
any significant questioning on the topic
either in government the senate or in
the media or elsewhere
and
elsewhere in his statement he says
preparedness had not featured
prominently before in my work that
changed when I had a part in exercise
cygnus
that would tend to suggest Dr Goodall
that at a high General level whilst
individual parts of the Welsh government
were getting on with doing what they
felt they needed to do for preparing the
Welsh people for the tier one risk of a
pandemic influenza
there was an absence of particular focus
by the government
on preparedness
would you agree I know the minister was
very personally involved in exercise
sickness but we would have taken some
confidence and at that point the
moderated schools
but I note The Minister's statement and
we would have raised those issues with
the minister if we had had significant
concern about our responses and
preparedness at that time but I know
that he obviously had reflected given
his involvement in exercise sickness
about its significance
had the risk reading for disruption
events including pandemic influenza gone
up between 2014 the first child we
looked at and 2019-20
the the overall yeah
risk had been mitigated the overall risk
score stated the same very high level
and what about the risk score after the
mitigating events are taken into account
the mitigation school had dropped from
12 to 8 and as I said we had used that
more in terms of the internal triggers
for business continuity so there was a
different assessment but the school had
gone down from 12 to 8. what does that
mean that the score had gone down from
12 to 8. it means that in respect of the
mitigations and that more General view
there was a view that those areas would
give a degree of confidence about the
responsiveness of the organization and
the triggers that we'd utilize
internally in the organization that
may we be clear please Dr Goodall the
reduction from 12 to 8 signified an
appreciation or acknowledgment by the
Welsh government
that the mitigating features the
measures that are identified to meet
that risk were no longer as effective as
they had been into
is that all right the school here would
mean that
there would have been more confidence
that the arrangements were working that
would have come back on experience of
instigating some of these Arrangements
like Disaster Recovery over that
previous time so it's a lower residual
score it was at that time showing a high
level of assurance the risk has gone
down from 8 out of 25
as it was
the state of fairness has got better
according to this risk management indeed
yes it had dropped from 12 to eight yes
and was that in part because further
actions were identified as having been
or actions were identified as having
been
put into place a business continuity
plan
generically Disaster Recovery
Arrangements were in place lessons were
being learned
and and response protocols were in place
it is that why the overall risk had gone
down because those things were being
done uh yes it was and also as I say
because of that
broader use of it as being the internal
trigger rather than a cross-wales
trigger
but the reality
was different was it not
because as you agreed yesterday
the the major civil contingencies
planning documents
the communicable disease plan the 2011
strategy the Health and Social Services
Group pandemic influenza response plan
none of them had been out updated
since 2014
the
transfer of functions order in 2018 had
taken place
but the Welsh government did not have
the full resources the capacity or the
structural system to be able to
accommodate those changes of executive
function
not all the recommendations from
exercise cygnus or talisin had been
implemented
and the work streams that did take place
throughout 2018 and 19 were
significantly interrupted by operation
yellowhammer
so how can those control or mitigation
measures have been properly advanced
as a reason for mitigating the overall
risk
yes in in hindsight on those scores with
the experience we went through that
residual School despite those broader
areas should have been higher but it
wasn't at the time but but Dr Goodall
somebody
compiling or somebody in the Welsh
government would have known when this
risk register was being compiled that
those mitigation measures were enlarged
to a large extent Chimera that they they
simply didn't reflect the reality of the
position on the ground did they
I think they were genuinely Reflections
at the time about the way in which we
had worked through various internal
Arrangements including business
continuity we'd had experiences around
disaster recovery and it would have been
demonstrating
some Assurance from the teams at that
time but I obviously can't change the
school that is there at that time do you
agree that those mitigation measures
were not accurately described in that
risk register at quarter one of 2019
those mitigating measures did not
reflect the reality of the absence of
work
within the Welsh government in terms of
the updating of the planning the
guidance the resourcing the response to
the exercises or the capacity to meet
the transfer of functions order I I
think personally in hindsight that
should have been a higher residual
school yes yes
and therefore those mitigating measures
identified there are inaccurate they
were simply not an adequate reflection
of the reality
um that they are generalized statements
but they would have been business
continuity Arrangements that were
referred to as part of that as well but
as I said the residual School in
hindsight should have been higher at
that time I agree with you Dr Goodall
they are either inaccurate or they are
too General yeah which is it uh I think
they were too generalized and that
probably gave some inappropriate
Assurance on Arrangements in there
um within the Health and Social Services
Group plan
we were able to highlight some other
higher level of actions that were taking
place on behalf of the sector and I hope
that that would have mitigated some of
that in terms of the way we worked our
way through those
briefly turning to some of those plans
and and the guidance
do you agree that the 2011 strategy the
UK pandemic influenza strategy
was not updated
before the pandemic struck in so far as
Wales was concerned
and that as it happened
doctrinally strategically it contained
as the evidence now very plainly
assumptions a number of flaws would you
agree with that proposition I I agree it
wasn't updated uh and I do agree
um given the emergence of Novel
coronavirus pandemic that there are a
number of assumptions in there that
directed us to not plan for a range of
areas and that might have included
Mass Gatherings uh non-pharmaceutical
interventions
we would have been Reliant more in a
pandemic flu response for a series of
opportunities to treat to vaccinate to
use antivirals almost as an initial
response and we simply didn't have that
within the coronavirus response but I do
agree that there were a range of areas
in there
which were not looking to contain
mechanisms and therefore more focus on
those non-pharmaceutical interventions
would have genuinely helped in the
response
and
were were all the
pan whales or Wales Centric
Health Emergency
pandemic influenza related guidance
documents all similarly
tainted by that strategic error so but
presumably the 2011 strategy which is a
UK document was looked at by the Welsh
government which would then rely upon it
for the purposes of drawing up its
communicable disease guidance its Health
and Social Services Group pandemic
guidance it's civil contingencies
guidance it's
panwell's response plan and so on but
they were all drawn weren't they
strategically from that
original single United Kingdom
documentary yes the UK document
um directed and was the framework that
we all worked within it set out the
strategy and that would have translated
through it would have been different
with some of the arrangements like the
outbreak plan for Wales because given
the particular Focus there there would
have been a focus on containment
rather than the pandemic flu principle
which was an expectation that it would
get to a level of community transmission
are therefore because the 2011 strategy
failed to recognize through the inherent
unpredictability of respiratory viruses
that
may be a
a non-influenza catastrophic outbreak
with different incubation periods
different transmission levels
different viral load impact
none of those issues or the associated
countermeasures that might have been
drawn out to deal with those problems
were addressed in any as with Scotland
panwell's documentation yeah there was
there was a strong focus on
um beyond the tech detection and
assessment stage to
be able to use in a pandemic flu context
treatments and antivirals and to deploy
those and that was unavailable to us
with the coronavirus pandemic on on the
updating of of documents that you raised
we did update the panuel's response plan
in 2019 we updated the health group
response activation in
2019 as well but but it would be right
to say that even if we had updated the
plan back in 2018
I don't feel that those underlying
principles would have necessarily
changed at that point and of course even
if we had updated them in Wales we would
have updated them again because of a UK
set of changes
whatever the variance whatever the
updates they were still harnessed to
that strategic yo
from the original document indeed and
and
the inevitable consequence of all that
was wasn't it that in the early weeks of
covid
and I I refer now to a statement from Mr
Kilpatrick
it became absolutely apparent that
the model which had to be drawn up from
scratch in the early days of
February and March 2020 simply didn't
align with the public health Wales
communicable disease outbreak plan which
of course was the
the Soul Plan
the wells was relying upon for dealing
with a communicable disease outbreak it
just it just didn't help them at all
yeah the the outbreak plan would have
tended to have been focused on outbreaks
in a more local setting and would tend
to be discharged within the local
resilience for a setting and obviously
the translation to a national level
would have been something different
certainly in
you know reviewing the infectious
diseases emergencies plan for Wales that
also was not really focusing on the
broader sort of societal issues that
were under review by the UK pandemic flu
plan and that equally
would have needed us to step in
differently at that kind of national
level
um I mean my view is is that
we were using the plans as the basis of
our response that it gave us foundations
and certainly that would be true of the
pan whales response plan but we had to
adapt very quickly to the emerging
situation and the knowledge that was
coming through very very quickly at that
time
all right
now maybe then templates to to plans
away from plans to exercises
the two major exercises with Ridge
um
we we need to be concerned are exercise
talusing and exercise sickness
are we not
exercise tallison was in 2009 what was
that a Welsh government or a United
Kingdom exercise uh that was actually a
United Kingdom exercise we discharged it
very significantly though in Wales right
I actually remember being part of that
exercise at the time because I was two
years into being a chief executive
and was that a
uh an exercise which
took place contemporaneously with the
swine flu outbreak
and therefore was able to pick up some
of the lessons that were learned
necessarily from the outbreak itself
yeah it almost immediately went into the
early part of the swine flu outbreak as
the exercise was taking place literally
within 24 48 hours
could you describe for us please the
width of that exercise how significant
it was and the generals in the general
Pantheon of of exercises because it was
in two parts I think that the first part
addressed the technical and procedural
aspects of communications
between local resilience forums the four
resilience forums in Wales and strategic
coordinating
centers which deal with the response as
opposed to planning and the second part
of the exercise appears to have been
and it took place on a single day
with
examining the Strategic decision making
of
the Strategic coordinating groups so it
appears in general terms to have been
addressing
the the mechanics and the working
practices of that lower level in The
Civil contingency structure the local
level in is that a fair summary yes at
the time I was a local Health Board
chief executive and would have had
involvement in those arrangements and
through you know my organization at the
time but yes it was looking to test the
resilience of those local agency
relationships and absolutely in the
context of the local resilience Forest
structures as well of course that was up
through the coordination mechanisms up
at the Welsh level as well
so the exercise didn't address directly
the workings in fact of the central
Welsh government so
that the workings of the
cabinet of the first minister or the
directorates including Health and Social
Services or that part of the government
but of course they were the bodies that
would receive whatever information was
coming from the local resilience forums
and the Strategic coordinating groups
well well I I would say and I I think
they were absolutely focused on ensuring
that those local resilience Arrangements
worked and responder organizations were
part of it but in the context of
working in Wales the structures would
have come together at the national level
as well and there would have been
involvement at that time from the Health
and Social Services Group it's
equivalent
could we have please one two eight nine
seven six which is the report from that
exercise
talisin swine flu structured debriefing
report it took place in the emergency
coordination Center
on the 18th of
[Music]
November
2009 although there was an earlier day
as I suggested I think in April where
there was
there was um
an exercise from eight till eight in the
evening for for strategic coordinating
groups and local resilience forums it
was prepared for the Wales resilience
partnership team
and if we could go please to page 13 I
think we'll find the recommendations
or conclusions
if you could scroll back out please
at the bottom of the page the following
conclusions are based on the issues
raised at the workshop for spine flu and
exercise talusin
in spite of pandemic flu being known as
the highest risk and with considerable
investment being made in recent years to
ensure that the United Kingdom is
prepared to cope with such an event a
number of gaps were exposed in plans
which need to be addressed ahead of a
more serious pandemic these issues in
particular are
and then if you could
could we scroll back out so that we can
get our
steps in relation to our bearings in
relation to the particular areas excess
deaths social care schools and early
years setting and over the page
information gathering
cultural approach based on the worst
case scenario and overall the response
to swine flu did not fully test the
plans in place so there were some quite
serious issues arising out of exercise
telesing on the areas which I've
identified
to what extent were those areas
still the focus of concern at the time
of exercise cygnus held in Wales
for whales alone in 2014.
four years later
so were all these issues addressed or do
they continue to pose concern
by the time of sickness yeah whilst
actions had taken place on those areas
looking at the list I haven't got the
whole list in front of me at this stage
but they were still concerns expressed
about Clarity of school closure
proposals as I've already indicated that
is something that would also go back to
some of the founding principles of the
2011 pandemic flu strategy
the social care responsiveness and
capacity in there albeit that there
would have been actions aside from
emergency planning that we would have
undertaken to have an understanding of
capacity and social care it's not line
managed like the NHS so it's a different
flow of information and on the excess
deaths whilst I know that there was work
that took place at that time it still
seemed that with exercise sickness we
still needed to provide Clarity and a
lot of that was around the changing
assumptions or the challenge to some of
the assumptions about potential deaths
as well so I think that was always a
point of modeling that seemed to be
asking for more Assurance in the system
as well and that was repeated for
exercise sickness
if we look at the cygnus recommendations
they're in 107 136
this is the the recommendation document
that came as uh as I've suggested from
that first part of exercise signals when
the United Kingdom adjourned delayed its
own exercise cygnus Wells meant ahead
with its part of cygnus in 2014.
and we can see that
the first paragraph
um refers the fact that a tier one UK
exercise was meant to be held in October
with three phases
they're initially 11 scheduled local
zones Forum scheduled to participate in
England they didn't of course because
that was put off while Wales had all
four of its local resilience forums
um agreed to agreeing to take part if we
could scroll back out please
strategic objectives were identified and
then exercise play the workshop as
identified and then right at the bottom
of the page we can see that the main
cross-governed element scheduled for the
week commencing 13 November was
postponed
could we then go to page two please
exercise outcomes a number of issues
were raised dealing with excess deaths
so that was still an issue by the time
of exercise sickness as you've you've
just rightly acknowledged communication
information demands and situation
reporting needs to be centralized to A
reduced duplication there needs to be
consistency of messaging across the
board does that mean communication in
the sense of media and dealing with the
public or communication between the
moving parts and the Civil contingencies
structure you're latter point the the
moving parts of the structures that
that's a
an important issue is it not it's an
important issue if they don't
communicate then the system isn't likely
to perform very well in terms of
responding to whatever emergencies
present themselves indeed that's true
and whilst different Arrangements
require different data flows yeah the
importance of
having enough data but also making sure
that there is enough time to be acting
on the back of that evidence and data as
well
regulation we needn't be overly
concerned with resources there needs to
be a national stockpile of resources
made available
school closures still an issue demands
for data collection still an issue
National pandemic flu service
one seg strategic coordinating Group
Express concern and then over the page
the recommendations
uh sorry the top of the page vulnerable
people concerns were expressed over the
capacity and Readiness of privately
owned Care Homes and robust contingency
plans
and then recommendations were made
so is this the position Dr Goodall a
number of features which had come out of
the earlier exercise had still not been
addressed by the time of exercise cygnus
and some of them were of considerable
importance and went to the centrality of
the Civil contingencies Health response
as a whole these were significant
matters yes some of those would have
continued and I would say that there
were activities taking place to
understand and address those areas but
they continued
teacher you know I know for example that
we were able to take Assurance back from
local resilience for on their views of
being able to manage access this on
modeling numbers
which took place back in I think 2018
um but I still don't feel that the work
was fully completed even by that point
on the back of the cygnus
recommendations certainly on on Care
Home understanding and capacity having
um Clarity on the local government
responsibilities and their local
business continuity plans for homes was
important and to seek that Assurance but
at the national level and this for me
was beyond just the emergency planning
response we did need to have more
understanding of simple issues like the
numbers of beds available across Wales
so
um in my director General role we did
commission and exercise to understand
that capacity
just to try and have a similar
understanding to the way in which we
would use some of our NHS data as well
but it was still not to full resolution
I agree
the issue of the capacity of the adult
care sector
cope with
the demands of an of a pandemic
was perhaps the most significant failing
identified at the time of exercise
sickness in 2014 was it not uh yes I
would agree that that was still an area
of concern it's it was the most
significant air of concern because it
directly went to matters
of life and death in the care home
sector
would you agree yeah indeed and it was a
serious issue for
um
local authorities and their discharge of
their responsibilities and it was
important to keep that Focus up as I
said
it's why we wanted to have a broader
understanding of those numbers
in 2016 the delayed United Kingdom
exercise took place
and it was a exercise which Wales
participated in
because the original exercise thing is
in 2014 had only been fairly limited
hadn't it and therefore it was obviously
desirable that the Welsh government
took part in the adjourned exercise in
2016. uh yes I agree and
the recommendations from that insofar as
whales were concerned
were contained in a document a Wales
debrief report one two eight nine seven
nine
October 16 exercise segments have taken
place earlier in October 16 so this is
obviously the degree report
and if if we could go please
just scroll through the first well let's
let's have a look at the first page we
can see there the reference references
to the nature of exercise cygnus tier
one UK pandemic flu exercise with full
ministerial participation in Wales the
exercise began on the 14th
continued on the 18th and it involved
again multi-agency groups from all four
local resilience forums
there was a the main exercises on the
19th and 20th with the CMO leading Cobra
officials at a meeting or leading
officials at a cobra meeting and the
cabinet secretary for health wellbeing
and sport that that would be Mr Vaughan
getting
and the minister for social services and
public health participating
there's then a reference to the NHS
workshop on the 14th and
have the local resilience Forum pandemic
planning checklist and various injects
were considered for the purposes of the
exercise
and if we go forward
to the the next page
there's a reference to countermeasures
aware awareness Workshop
and then if you would bear with me one
moment
we'll go straight to the recommendations
page
while we wait for that to come up um is
it right that the overall position was
that there were there we are thank you
very much indeed
very sharp attention by uh brilliant
technician page four recommendations one
all organizations were asked to review
their pandemic plans
to all organizations to ensure the
sufficient awareness of what is within
the Welsh national stockpile through all
organizations review their local
delivery points and antiviral collection
points
if we could just scroll further forward
one page we'll see whether any more
recommendations and there weren't
so insofar as Wales was concerned only a
small number of the recommendations from
the overarching exercise were relevant
uh there were there were more
recommendations than that I think of use
growth oh is that because the
recommendations lit up in sections by
reference to particular parts of the
exercise particular Parts all right yes
there we are page seven
if recommendations four and five I
believe there were 12 in all there were
12 uh within the Welsh context uh there
were there were 22 obviously when the
overall exercise sickness
recommendations came through and I would
say that they also remained relevant to
us of course
of the 12 recommendations of the overall
22 recommendations the 12 that were
relevant to Wales
how many of those recommendations
concerned issues
which had still not been addressed from
the earlier talising exercise in the
earlier sickness exercise
um
because of our particular use of this
exercise we hadn't quite gone into all
of those arrangements in that way but
certainly the the broader exercise
sickness recommendations and the 22 they
would have continued to show some
consistent concerns that even if plans
or activities were taking place they
still hadn't
come to the best outcome that would give
resilience in those arrangements as well
so the we took the Wales our
recommendations and Drew them into the
exercise sickness recommendations just
for ease of access
the reality was wasn't it that the
concerns about the adult social care
sector had not gone away
two years later
the communication issue had not gone
away but in addition by the time of the
excise sickness exercise report in 2016
there was then additional concerns being
expressed about countermeasures the
stockpiling is that correct there was a
wish to understand the level of
provision that had been made to have
Assurance on those countermeasure
arrangements but as part of the Welsh
response at the time we had particularly
wanted to test and exercise that so it
didn't mean that we didn't have stocks
or countermeasures in place it was just
making sure that they were going to be
um appropriate for the modeling data
that was emerging through exercise
sickness as well so that was an
intention for us to try and focus
particularly on those counter measures
and
was it at that point that the Welsh
government set up the wells pandemic flu
task and finish group
about which you you debated the merits
of
the merits of which with my lady
yesterday was that the task and Finnish
group that was put into place to try to
address such concerns as they were
coming out finally out of exercise
sickness in 2016. yes they were the
Practical arrangements and of course we
reached out to the UK pandemic flu
arrangements as well and were observing
and part of those arrangements and
participating
but that task and finish group as you
said yesterday wasn't able to finish its
work because although it identified the
tasks it never finished them
and also as I said yesterday we ended up
moving our resilience activity and focus
onto other matters on the exercise
particular Arrangements
15 of the actions were completed
um seven of them were still not marked
as complete and under consideration
um
I can describe how on some of those
measures I think that they actually had
more significant activity as an example
there was a draft communication strategy
that had been worked on and was
available but it hadn't been issued
um we had worked through a draft extreme
surge guidance plan but at that point it
wasn't issued it was only in draft and
under consideration so there were a
number of areas that we hadn't finalized
or completed as I said yesterday
it may be thought Dr Goodall that in the
event of a
disease outbreak and a pandemic
two of the most vital
concerns would be the ability to
surge
your provision of health services
and a second would be your ability to be
able to provide adequate care
and resource to vulnerable people
particularly those in the care sector
in order to be able to deal with the
terrible consequences of a pandemic
it was those two areas The Surge
planning and
the guidance and the arrangements for
the protection of the adult social care
sector
that were not addressed
by the task and Finnish Group after 2016
even though those were eras which had
been flagged up as long ago before as
exercise talisen
correct
whilst the extreme surge guidance hadn't
been issued it was available as a draft
and ultimately we were able to use that
when we were responding very quickly to
the coronavirus pandemic but as I
indicated
it wasn't issued
um in respect of the care home
resilience Arrangements it was really
important to maintain a focus on those
arrangements absolutely and to make sure
we were able to take Assurance from the
sectors and the systems reporting into
us
in addition to this incomplete task and
finish process
did the Welsh government
following something called the Pollock
review a few years before which had been
a review specifically commissioned
to address why was the lessons weren't
being learned from reviews and inquiries
set up
something called The Joint
organizational learning strategy
a body called the Wales Learning and
Development Group
and then ultimately
the Wales pandemic flew preparedness
group
to also look into why learning was not
being properly put into place following
exercises
it did do that and it also led to
um
the arrangements put in place
first of all we're training which had
been instigated back in 2008 but also
the pattern of the annual conferences
both generally for civil contingencies
and also for the health sector that
allowed us to be able to draw in those
mechanisms with the organizations and
the first responder arrangements as well
so they also allowed us to have an
understanding of the focus of those
activities over that time as well but
that additional and I'm sorry I've
described it repeatedly as labyrinthine
process
itself wasn't able to ensure that all
the recommendations and the learning
from the various exercises were put into
place
was it now as I said yesterday that
there were actions that were incomplete
and in particular
as a result of resourcing problems
we looted this through sir Frank
Atherton
the Strategic decision taken to a weight
work from Whitehall before getting on
with doing work in Wales on the
pandemic flu preparedness group work
streams and also because of the
diversion of attention away from civil
contingencies planning towards the
necessary preparations for a No Deal EU
exit
those work streams
were never completed
uh yes you're right and we obviously uh
talked about operation yellowhammer
yesterday and the way in which it needed
to take resources within the
organization although that did give us
some insight into sector resilience
plans more generally that's part of that
process
standing back in relation to the areas
of concern expressed after cygnus
one of the key issues during exercise
cygnus was as I've suggested to you
Healthcare demand the surge in demand
for critical care
that work was still being finalized in
2018.
but it never reached fruition did it it
was still in draft at that time there
had actually been guidance issued on
critical care surge earlier I think back
in 2012
um it was never updated was it it wasn't
no I I do agree with that although it
had been worked on with colleagues and
experts within that particular system
but I I agree that it hadn't been
updated by that point but there was
Critical Care search guidance
the consideration that it was thought
necessary to give to reviewing and
amending the pandemic influenza
framework for local authorities and
Social Services providers
was never complete
it wasn't completed but we did through
our resilience arrangements and take
Assurance from local resilience fora on
their preparedness and also from local
authorities as First Responders on their
arrangements so there was an assurance
linked through to whether those
organizations felt that their plans were
sufficiently resilient or robust
there was no National resilience
structure Assurance structure put into
place in the way that there is in
England and
um
in respect of local resilience forums in
England there was no National resilience
Standard Process put into place a
national resilience assurance
process by which
local residence forums could be checked
put into place either there was a
self-assessment process for them within
the responsibilities that Welsh
government had before 2018 before it had
the legal duties
it didn't have the performance in
Insurance role but from 2018 it would
have allowed us to start discharging
those Assurance roles and there was a
sector resilience Assurance exercise
that was undertaken in 2018 and it was
in the context of pandemic flu
was there any non-self assessment any
external Insurance process for checking
the validity the worth the merits of the
plans that were being put into place to
deal with the pandemic influenza it was
generally a self-assessment process for
lrs and also for individual
organizations
um we had used some peer review examples
where Welsh local resilience
Forum would
look at each other's progress and make
assessments
there was in 2018
an understanding that
following the transfer of functions
order there needed to be a review
generally of the Civil contingencies
structure in Wales
is that yeah yes I agree we needed to
understand how we were going to properly
and fully discharge those
responsibilities
and what happened to that General review
of civil contingencies following the
transfer of functions order
and whilst we had done the sector
resilience oversight and we had expanded
the team
with the new responsibilities coming
over
our attention and activity had simply
moved across to operation
yellowhammer and the EU exit
arrangements and that meant that the
resilience team was embedded in that
work as well as a very large part of the
organization as well so
the discharging of those
responsibilities as we instead intended
was was put on pause even though we were
using and deploying the Civil
contingency mechanisms for EU exit
the inability to carry out that review
of course
an inability which
existed
prior to Wales being struck by the
pandemic has been described by one of
our own ministers as extremely
disappointing you've seen the reference
of Mr Kilpatrick's statement
and even after the pandemic struck
when the review of civil contingencies
in Wales took place in 2023
did earlier this year did it not it did
it then become apparent
that there were still flaws in the Civil
contingency system in particular in
relation to
leadership capacity
effective and continuous training and
exercising
a system for the systematic capture of
lessons from exercises the need for an
establishment of minimum standards
competency skills qualifications
training
and development
yes indeed they Remain the themes in
those areas and that work is underway to
make sure that they are resolved that
there is a system that captures the
Lessons Learned now which has held on an
all Wells level by public health whales
and that is a new introduction since
2017 but we do need to make sure that we
embed those arrangements and deal with
the actions as well as the culture and
behavior around those issues as well
so Dr good or would you agree
that given that many of those issues
have been raised consistently
continuously from 2012 onwards
that is an egregious example of locking
the stable door after the horse is
bolted
we've had to learn many lessons on adapt
and you know we need to ensure that we
keep addressing the issues from our
planning and also from our recent
experiences as well
I have no other questions
lady you give him permission for three
years of questioning to be Advanced by
covid-19 bereaved families for justice
Camry thank you
good morning I'm bethan Harris I appear
on behalf of covid-19 for we families
for justice
I have three questions Dr Goodall and uh
I have 10 minutes so I'll be keeping an
eye on the time
yesterday sir Frank Atherton when he was
giving his evidence he was referred to a
document which had been produced for the
health protection Advisory Group
and for the reference that is 177362
I won't take you to that document but
I'd just like to read first of all what
he said in evidence he was taken to the
document and it was introduced to him as
a paper prepared for the committee
that's the health protection Advisory
Group in July 2019 six months before the
pandemic struck
and the document contained within it
this statement the current microbiology
stroke infection services in Wales are
fragile and are struggling to deliver on
a day-to-day basis the prevention early
diagnosis and Frontline support that
professionals and the public require
he was asked whether that was not a
major concern and he agreed it was a
major concern
yeah
I'd like to ask you about a document
that you've referred to in your witness
statement that you've exhibited it's and
I could if it could be brought up on the
screen please the number is 177552
you've referred to it in your third
witness statement at paragraph one two
eight
and hopefully that can be brought up on
the screen
thank you I think it's there
this is an a ministerial advice you see
it Dr Goodall yes I can thank you thank
you
um and it's addressed to the minister of
Health and Social Services it's dated
the 2nd of September 2019.
subject strengthening and improving the
National Health Protection Service in
Wales
box one what is the issue you're asking
the minister to consider this advice
summarizes the current health protection
challenges faced in Wales and sets out
the investment needed to meet this
Challenge and to strengthen and improve
our national health Protection Service
and then it goes on to refer to the
actions that are being recommended which
are to increase the revenue that's
necessary and indeed we heard sir Frank
Atherton refer to the request for
additional Revenue in this area when he
gave his evidence yesterday
I'd like to refer you to what is stated
with regards to the context which is on
the next page if we could kindly go to
that on the screen please headed advice
for context what is the situation that
has led to this advice
first of all the recent terrorism
incident in Salisbury is referred to
uncertainties caused by EU exit growing
threats posed by antimicrobial
resistance increased threat of high
consequence infectious disease such as
Ebola and then goes on to refer to
International domestic events
demonstrated fragilities in all the
respective National Health Protection
Services operating within the UK which
the responsible authorities in all four
nations are seeking to address
then it goes on to say response to these
threats relies on the same physical and
human infrastructure which is currently
Under Pressure to deliver basic health
Protection Services health professionals
in Wales are not confident that they
could at all times provide an effective
response to high consequence infections
or other chemical and biological threats
the National Health Protection Service
in Wales is fragile
and the service today is confronted by a
number of challenges these include
and then first of all it refers to a
uk-wide shortages of trained staff
and then laboratory Estates on many
sites which are no longer fit for
purpose
the next bullet point the need for
increased ward-based Clinical Services
and services in the communities to
support both infection prevention and
antimicrobial stewardship
and then goes on to say although
microbiology is a shortage of specialty
uk-wide recruitment to Wales is
particularly challenging when the
laboratory estate on many sites is not
fit for purpose and a lack of investment
in new technologies and redeployment of
scientists means microbiologists are
unable to spend time on Frontline
supporting professionals I'm going to
skip the next paragraph and then finally
that Health protection Professionals in
Wales consider that adequately resourced
there is much more they could contribute
in the prevention diagnosis and
management of infection and in guiding
prudent use of antibiotics
so that as I say is a document that
you've exhibited and what I'd like to
ask you about is first of all do you
agree that the document that initially
referred to the one that sir Frank
Atherton was referred to yesterday
and this particular document in
September 2019
they imply that there was a very real
need to improve on infection prevention
and control services in Wales at that
time in 2019.
uh yes I I remember uh not just the
document but the discussion at the time
it was a very honest assessment
um that had come through that group
also uh on the advice and expertise of
Public Health Wales and it was really
important that we were responding to
those concerns about fragility and the
decision was made to support that in
fact the previous year we had actually
made some additional Financial
investment in public health Wales in
this Arena as well and do you agree that
in terms of pandemic preparedness and
being prepared for the tier one risk
that everyone across the UK including in
Wales was aware of that there would need
to be capacity to meet a significant
increase in Need for infection
prevention and control services yeah yes
indeed I mean the NHS faces day-to-day
pressures whilst it's discharging many
activities and supporting its
communities
the day-to-day pressures of the service
you know would need to have some
resilience built in to be able to deal
with those extra responsibilities as
well so yes the existing service was
under pressure which was why we were
addressing it but we were also trying to
build in some resilience into the system
with the investment as well
and going to what I think you're saying
and I'll ask you to confirm were the two
or two of the main
pandemic preparedness planning documents
I'm going to ask you whether they
actually reflect the importance of
infection control and prevention first
of all if you can perhaps confirm that
the Wales framework for managing major
infectious disease emergencies
October 2014
was one of the main
preparatus preparedness guidance
documents
that was current in Wales from 2014
onwards right up to when the pandemic
hit yes it would have covered
responsibilities and maybe not gone into
all of the detail certainly the outbreak
plan for Wales would have really dealt
with some of the very specific issues in
terms of discharging that in a local
level yes thank you
so that's one of the documents and it's
right isn't it that that document the
Wales framework for managing major
infectious disease emergencies you may
be familiar with its content without me
needing to take you specifically to the
documents but I'd like to refer you to a
passage in it
and uh it was indeed a passage that was
highlighted yesterday again in sir Frank
atherton's evidence paragraph 11.1 all
hospitals need to establish ways of
caring for large numbers of infectious
patients on a scale outside their normal
experience including those requiring
High dependency care so just to confirm
that document clearly recognized the
importance of infection control in the
context of being prepared for a pandemic
yes
and the the other
um the other document is the Wales
Health and Social care influencer
pandemic preparedness and response
guidance again another one of the major
preparedness guidance documents
2014 that remained in force throughout
up until the pandemic hit
yes yes indeed yeah we'd hope to review
it in 2018 but it was the document in
2014 that was an important response
document for us yes and that one
referred to
two Patrol procedures
um being part of
um preparedness and part of what would
be needed in the event of uh a pandemic
yes that's familiar too thank you so
what I want to ask you is do you accept
that when we when we look at what we had
in September 2019 in the documents I
referred you to which you've exhibited
and we look at those documents in 2014
and what they flag up in terms of needs
in terms of infection and prevention
control that there just wasn't a robust
enough process of following up on what
the Welsh government's own guidance said
that there wasn't a critical review as
to whether things were actually put in
place that had been stated in the
documents
we've worked with individual health
boards in Wales
um who would have used their funding for
a variety of areas Public Health whales
of course would have made its assessment
and when it came forward with its
National plan we were very happy to
support it I mean certainly and I speak
from personal experience as a local
Health Board chief executive we had
tried to ensure that new hospital bills
were supporting an infection control
Outlook including single room
arrangements for example but that was
not available to all of the Estates they
were certainly possible with new build
Arrangements in Wales but we would have
worked with individual organizations on
there proposals and plans and they would
have been able to make some local
decisions on that infrastructure as well
right so you're saying things were done
but do you accept it wasn't enough
when we were receiving that National
Protection and proposal that was showing
that we needed to invest more and have
more flexibility and capacity yes okay
I'm going to just deal with my a second
question very briefly because I know
that I'm I'm running out of the time
that's allocated thank you for those
answers I'd like to ask you a question
on PPE and
um
perhaps putting to one side matters of
what the arrangements were with regards
to how much PPE was stockpiled and what
was the extent of the actual
availability of PPE that was planned and
and put in place
uh
was the distribution system for
accessing PPE and distributing it was
the resilience of that system in Wales
adequately tested in advance of the
pandemic
the
PPE stockpiles where we were making sure
that we had about 15 weeks worth of
Supply available were well tested
when we were in the coronavirus response
we really had to utilize the Excellence
of the national procurement service
arrangements to change the distribution
model quite quickly but to your question
I don't think that they were rigorously
tested they may well have featured as
part of the procurement Services own
resilience proposals but certainly we
adapted very quickly to ensure we could
distribute the PPE out to at least the
regional Centers before they needed to
go through to the front line staff and
services
and just finally
um
obviously this module is not looking at
what actually transpired and how things
played out on the ground in any detail
but do you acknowledge that there were
problems with distribution
we ended up having to change our
distribution model rather than to 11
centers to literally get to hundreds of
sites in matters of days so it was a
very different
response that was required at the time
and
in retrospect
would it be right to say that there
hadn't been sufficient scrutiny of the
resilience of that distribution system
in advance of the pandemic
we were assured on the existing
Arrangements but at the scale the
severity and the duration of the
arrangements we would have needed to
have done more work based on the
experience that we had to the
coronavirus pandemic
thank you thank you my lady those are my
questions thank you very much I'm a lady
I'm admitted to ask about one particular
area which I know has been a concerned
photographer's been going for a long
time is it important to do it's about
the chief Scientific Advisor system in
Wales and I wanted to ask two questions
in relation to that
if I may
Dr Goodall it is this that the it
appears the material that the chief
Scientific Advisor for health in Wales a
man
who is actually I think a Mr Rob Orford
because he's concerned with being the
chief Scientific Advisor for health is
not part of the UK
Chief Scientific Advisor system
and secondly do we have a right that for
whatever reason the chief Scientific
Advisor in Wales and the chief
Scientific Advisor for health in Wales
are not at the center of the Welsh
civil contingency structure so they
don't actually give advice on civil
contingencies to the Welsh government
have I have I summarized the position
correctly yeah you've summarized those
uh correctly there were some changed
Arrangements put in place during the
pandemic itself to access those but they
were certainly robbers the CSA Health
was involved in the pandemic response
but they had traditionally not been
directly involved in the preparedness
thank you
thank you very much and I shall return
at 22. all right
foreign
my lady Maya please call Dr Quentin
sander for Obe
I swear by almighty God
the evidence I shall give
shall be the truth
the halters
are nothing but
Dr sandova thank you very much for the
assistance you've so far given to this
inquiry and also thank you for coming to
give evidence today you have prepared a
witness statement which we see at 192
266 your signature appears at page 83
there we are you signed this statement
on the 27th of February this year can
you confirm please that it's true to the
best of your knowledge and belief yes
thank you and my lady may we have
permission to publish it thank you I'd
like we can take that down I'd like to
begin by establishing through you Dr
sanderfer the creation of Public Health
Wales it was formulated in 2009 by the
minister of Health and Social Services
following a review of Public Health
functions undertaken in 2006 is that
right
correct thank you
the functions of Public Health whales
are threefold it provides data and
science-based Leadership
specializing in public health expertise
and coordination and advice and is a
delivery of key Public Health Services
second it works closely with public
health boards local authorities and
other partners including education and
housing and third it protects and
improves the health and well-being and
seeks to reduce Health inequalities is
that right
correct thank you
the structure of Public Health Wales has
a senior management team that has
changed in certain respects since its
incorporation in 2009 but the chief
executive since 2014 has operated a
corporate level business executive team
structure where collective decision
making at a corporate level is a key
feature in addition to each director
having clear accountability and
responsibility for a specific portfolio
is that right that's correct and the
second key role is that of national
director for health protection and
screening services executive medical
director a title which was previously
known as the executive director for
public health services medical director
that's correct and I held that latter
title from October 2012 until December
2020. thank you and
in your role as at executive level
responsibility which we'll go into in
more detail detail throughout the course
of your evidence this morning
or is it right that you have now become
a consultant advisor for pandemic and
international health for public health
Wales
following my retirement in December 2020
I returned in 2021 and undertook that
contracted consultancy our role on a
part-time basis
thank you
I want to turn to deal with the funding
of Public Health Wales
and to
confirm with you please Dr Sandifer that
there are two main sources of funding
for the organization funding from the
Welsh government and other National
Health Service Wales organizations who
provide
remuneration for the provision of
services delivered by public health
workers that's correct you tell us at
paragraph 41 in your witness statement
that in exercising its role and
functions Public Health Wales was not
held back in any way by the funding made
available by the Welsh government and
that in your view there are no examples
of insufficient funding curtailing the
ability to fulfill Public Health Wales
role and functions in a timely manner in
relation to the pandemic is that right
that's right
um Public Health Wales funding increased
dramatically from 2009 to 2010 when it
was set at 41.5 million to
152.9 Million by the time we reached
2019 to 2020.
what was the cause of that dramatic
increase in funding and why was it made
well the figure that you started with
the 41 million reflected a half year
position because the organization was
established at the beginning of October
2009.
and the full year figure which is
reflected in the
2010-2011 accounts was around 81 million
at the principal reason for the
expansion in funding was partly as a
result of some transfers of
of functions that were discharged in
other bodies uh in Wales transferring
into public health whales with the
funding attached to those and also in
part as a result likewise of some
service transfers for example our
diabetic retinopathy service was
transferred in from a local Health Board
into public health Wales and brought
with it a substantial amount of
financial resources and then there were
some other additional Investments made
by Welsh government during the course of
the 10 years
including in health protection but also
in other areas like policy research
international Health development thank
you
can you confirm for the purposes up
for public health Wales is a category
one responder yes it is and so as well
as having Health protection and
microbiology responsibilities it also
had an eprr function didn't it it did
and in terms of the allocation of budget
for emergency preparedness resilience
and response functions that increased
from 2014 to 2015 and 387
000 to 2020 to 2021 800 884
000 pounds
can you explain why there was such a
dramatic increase in that part of the
budget please yes I think it's fair to
say it's very difficult to tease out
what exactly
worthy Financial elements attached to
eprr because of course eprr is a
function delivered by the whole of the
organization and in particular from our
health protection and microbiology
services but I do recognize those
figures and the reason why there was
such an increase is that following the
Ebola outbreak in Wales in 2014 to 2016
um and uh on the back of uh reviews that
we undertook both to our emergency
planning and business continuity
Arrangements
uh we introduced some uh changes in
2017-2018
including for example expansion of our
emergency planning support Workforce the
appointment of a lead manager and all of
those appointments attracted uh the need
for further investment
did you think at the time in 2014 to
2015 that the eprr budget was sufficient
I think Public Health Wales
discharged its EP RR functions within
the resources available to it but in
doing so at that time it should be said
that the eprr function was located in
our health Protection Team
and it is probably true to say that it
was subsidized
by the health Protection Service
will you tell us at paragraph 196 in
your witness statement that the health
Protection Services in public health
Wales were underpowered what did you
mean by that
so that paragraph refers to our
assessment of the initial phase of the
coronavirus response
so if I could just summarize perhaps to
help the inquiry understand the pattern
of investment
between 2010 and
2019 there had been no budget cuts and
there had been an increase in both the
financial resources
and the workforce in the health
protection and microbiology services
which is where most of the eprr
functions were based and from which they
were delivered
well just before we leave the issue of
finance and budget
um you also tell us at paragraph 78 that
in February 2019 the Welsh government
confirmed additional funding for the
National Health Protection Service and
that there was one million pounds
Capital funding in that year to directly
support the automation of the laboratory
services across Wales and 0.6 million
pounds minimum revenue for the continued
development of the pathogen genomics
unit
that's correct and that reflected in
fact a series of Investments that had
been made
since 2014
in our in our health protection
and our microbiology services
Dr Tracy Cooper your successor in post
tells us in her witness statement that
that funding facilitated enhancements to
the microbiology laboratory network and
infrastructure but that those
improvements were still being made and
implemented at the time of the pandemic
do you agree with that
um if I could just gently correct Dr
Tracy Coopers the chief executive of
Public Health Wales and had been so
since June of 2014 and remained still
the chief executive thank you
um but uh to your point yes that that is
correct all right and she also told us
that that was that funding was only a
part A Part response to the need raised
by public health whales for the
strengthening of the health protection
system across Wales so she appears to be
saying and please correct me if I'm
wrong that that a plea had been made for
further investment and the investment in
terms of the laboratory services that
was received was only a part response do
you agree with that well it was we began
our discussions with Welsh government in
uh the second half of 2017 about what we
regarded as the additional investment
required to strengthen our national
health Protection Service
um this uh also coincided with what we
believed was some necessary Investments
such as you referred to the capital
investment
in particular Technologies molecular
Diagnostics and genomics
sequencing in particular
but uh
and we were grateful for the investment
that we did receive but we had still
anticipated and therefore made the case
for further investment which then came
through later in 2019
it is that partly because in 2017-2018
uh the the uh the organization
identified to the Welsh government in
particular the need to strengthen the
health protection system and what Dr
Cooper describes as a particularly
fragile microbiology service
yes
and do you agree that at the time and
before that investment was made the the
microbiology Services were particularly
fragile
yes that fragility was created in a
2015-2016
with a retirement of a number of senior
microbiologists and difficulties what we
had recruiting to those uh posts
and the investment uh
um that we refer to the fragility and
the investment we referred to was
accompanied actually also by some
internal actions we took to strengthen
as a model for the delivery of
microbiology at the same time
to what extent did Public Health Wales
provide advice to the Welsh government
on its pandemic preparedness
so Public Health Wales has throughout
its existence
specialist advice
and direct support systems leadership to
Welsh government and the wider Health
social care and local government system
in Wales in respect of eprr and so yes
that included uh specific advice to
Welsh government on its pandemic
planning Arrangements Learning and
Development
exercising and training
what level of representation did Public
Health whales have on scientific
advisory bodies such as sage and nerve
tag
so Public Health Wales has never been a
member or at least have put it the other
way around
representation from public health Wales
there has been no representation from
public health whales on nerve track
likewise we've not had a seat on Sage
pre-pandemic
Wales deserved a place on nerve tag and
Sage
I do think that it would be beneficial
for public health whales to be on nerve
tag I recognize that Sage is established
in specific circumstances and that
government representation would be the
most appropriate sitting outside of
government we didn't presume that that
would include us but we would of course
always be happy to support Welsh
government had we been asked
in terms of responsibility at a local
level Public Health Wells duties and
responsibilities and its obligations
indeed under the Civil contingencies act
meant that it worked closely with local
resilience fora is that right yes we had
representation on four all four local
resilience fora in Wales and did Public
Health Wales also chair the Wales risk
group
we did one on the senior manager for our
combined in 2017-18 we combined our
business continuity and emergency
planning Arrangements our business our
manager for that service did lead that
group from uh January 2018 till November
2020.
what if any discussion was there during
the meetings of that group about the
national risk assessment
so what that group did is it took the
and then with Welsh government and with
representatives from the four local
resilience forum
uh considered how that risk assessment
applied within Wales and the steps and
actions that should be taken including
the
inclusion of the risks in local
resilience for a community risk
registers and did that also involve an
assessment of any
we also as I've already said had
representation at the local level and
our representation at the local level
included uh liaison with each of the
local resilient fora about their
assessed risks and Advising them
accordingly
how did Public Health
rearrangements in place to effectively
support and enable the local resilience
for to make their own rapid and
effective responses to the pandemic when
it struck
so Public Health uh Wales is Health
protection team together with the
microbiology service
used our emergency response plan as the
basis
for our initial response to the pandemic
in 2020 and in doing so we were aware
that the local resilience for in turn
were standing up their strategic
coordinating groups as is appropriate as
a response
what is the rails resilience forum and
how does public health Wells contribute
to that Wales resilience forum
is a structure within Welsh government
that is chaired by the first Minister
and includes representation from all
multi-agency Partners at a strategic
level to consider the risks across the
piece so not confined only to health
um and I represented uh Public Health
Wales as a member of that group how does
that sit with Wales resilience
partnership team
the Wales resilience partnership team
was a group underneath the Wales
resilience fora in part providing
Secretariat functions and in part
tasked with the operationalization of
some of the activities
that had been discussed at the Wales
resilience Forum did you also sit on the
Wales resilience partnership team I
didn't but our emergency planning and
business continuity manager did right
thank you
all right now having established the the
body that public health Wales became in
2009 and its functions and
responsibilities I'd like to now look at
some of the plans that were in place
um over the course of the module one
time period and first of all please can
we look at
89558 which is the public health Wales
emergency response plan we can see that
this version is version two created in
September of 2018 and if we go to page
two please
we can see that under the um
Under The Heading sponsoring executive
you appear as the sponsoring executive
what does that mean in terms of this
particular document
what that means is that that's the
executive lead for
um public health emergency planning in
Wales uh this document uh was endorsed
by me and commended on by myself to our
board for consideration and what was the
purpose of this document how was it
intended to be used
so this document as it says at the top
provides a specific arrangement for our
strategic and tactical response to
emergencies instance and outbreaks
and it's the top level document of a
suite of documents also that sit with
this it is an internal document but it
has been written very much in the spirit
of the Civil contingencies Act was
shared with and therefore deliberately
made known and to our local resilience
for our partners so that they had access
to this they and Welsh government had
access to this document thank you can we
go to page nine please and look at
paragraph 1.1
thank you we can see here
um under the heading introduction that
public health Wales emergency response
plan details the organization's response
arrangements to any emergency incident
or outbreak that impact on or requires
the mobilization of Public Health
Resources and capabilities the emergency
response plan provides a framework to
establish create and improve resilience
did this document replace a an earlier
iteration and if so when was that first
created please
so this document replaced an earlier
version which had been approved by our
board in November 2016.
and indeed it was about the fifth I'd
have to just remind myself we had a plan
in 20 2009 2012 2014 2016 and yes this
would have been the fifth iteration of
the plan
in 2018.
it wasn't updated was it until
2022 I think
that's uh simply because uh events over
took us at the beginning of 2020
which is I mean we review our plans
annually anyway uh the plan uh was still
uh we considered relevant at the
beginning of the outbreak of the
pandemic but we uh during the course of
the pandemic recognized uh that the plan
would need updating and at the earliest
appropriate time we did so thank you can
we go to page 10 please and have a look
at the roles and responsibilities
um we can see
that third row from the bottom
um can we just scroll out please here we
are facilitate epidemiological follow-up
of affected populations and communities
as necessary
to what extent did Public Health Wales
achieve this what what was this intended
to represent
so um in uh an incident an emergency
particularly in an outbreak
um
what we uh always sought to do was to
assess the impact of that on the
population's affected
we did this during the covert response a
wide range of Assessments were
undertaken including epidemiological
assessment but an example would be had
there been a chemical release from a
factory with a cloud of gas
discharged and floating over a local
population
we would
follow after that event had been
resolved we might well follow up with
the affected population to see if
there's been any longer term impact
do you agree that within this document
the eprr
information largely focuses on command
and control measures and doesn't include
any specific detail on how to Handler
coronavirus outbreak and it doesn't go
into any plan for
non-pharmaceutical interventions
so I think um I should explain that uh
this plan which is an all hazards plan
it's a generic plan uh was written in
the context of uh Public Health Wales as
a category one responder being able to
demonstrate that it was fulfilling the
requirements of the Civil contingencies
Act and the duties and respect
in statutory guidance and that is the
how document has been written so so it
is your answer that you wouldn't have
expected that level of detail to be
involved or incorporated into a document
such as this I would expect that
information to be in other documents
right well we'll
in a moment but but before we do we can
take that down please I'd like to ask
you about the health protection Advisory
Group
um that is a group that had been or
indeed has been in existence for many
years hasn't it
it has yes and it was
um it involved the CMO the chief medical
officer for Wales
but you tell us in your witness
statement that there was a period of
abeyance of the group
for it was re-established in May of
2018. why was the group put into
abeyance at which which required it to
be re-established in May of 2018.
so uh the group is a non-statutry
Advisory Group to the chief medical
officer
and in 2014 the then chief medical
officer retired
and the group therefore ceased to meet
the current chief medical officer came
into post later in the uh
um and then at the beginning of 2018
uh he decided that he would like to
re-establish the group what was the
involvement of Public Health Wales in
that group
Public Health Wales has always been a
member of the health protection Advisory
Group
and to what extent was pandemic
preparedness discussed during those
group meetings
so the group looked at the whole breadth
of Public Health
uh threats and Hazards
and public health Wales
advised
and supported the group for example by
preparing technical documents and papers
for it to consider
and influence a pandemic preparedness
had been one of the subjects of
discussion in the group and what was
discussed about it
so um we had uh
been aware that uh in 2016 or 2014 as
has been discussed already
there had been an exercise in Wales and
that there had also been an exercise at
the UK level that Wales had participated
in and that had generated
recommendations and outputs which needed
to be followed through and so did Public
Health whales become involved with the
recommendations that that fell out of
exercise cygnus and the other exercises
that ran before that which we'll turn to
look at in a moment so when uh exercise
sickness took place Public Health Wales
had two Representatives observing
when the report was published in July of
2017 we obviously received a copy of
that report and as was shown yesterday
a Wales influenza pandemic preparedness
group was convened meeting first in
September that year and public health
Wales was represented on that group
all right well we'll come to to look at
that in a moment but before we do let's
just have a look at a set of meetings
from this group from the 17th of
December of 2019 when the health
protection Advisory Group
uh met and we can see from the first
page
um that public health whales were
represented by Andrew Jones
um you sent your apologies for that
meeting we can see that halfway down the
page but but no doubt you will have been
filled in by what what took place during
the course of the meeting and any
recommendations that came out of it
yes I was on annual leave uh Andrew
Jones is my Deputy thank you can we go
to page four please of the
eating notes and look at paragraph 5.2
thank you
we can see that the CMO acknowledged
that there were significant questions
around the preparedness of NHS Wales to
deal with a similar situation and to be
able to manage an infected case at one
of our acute hospitals for at least 24
hours it was agreed that whilst a key
work stream of strengthening the
National Health Protection Service would
look at an all-well system for dealing
with high consequence infections more
urgent action was necessary to provide
reassurance to what does this relate
please
so this relates to discussions that were
taking place at the time about the
development of a high consequence
infectious diseases unit in Wales yes
at that time
it was necessary for any patient that
had a high consequence infectious
disease to be transferred to a
designated unit in England yes right
well if we look at the bottom of this
paragraph we can see that action 23 was
for the CMO to write to health boards
and public health Wales and Wast
requesting their plan or pathway for
dealing with a high consequence
infectious disease the deadline for
which was March 2020. do you know
whether or not that was done
so um in January 2020
as it became clear touching Public
Health Wales the novel coronavirus
represented a very serious threat
we as an organization entered into
discussions with Welsh government and
with one of our local Health boards to
discuss how we could establish very
quickly a high consequence infectious
disease unit at that hospital
in advance Sovereign Readiness for
potential patients if novel coronavirus
came to Wales all right
I'd like we could we can take down
please I'd like to now look at the
emergency planning and business
continuity group and to look at the
terms of reference for this group which
are at 89648
thank you
thank you we can see that's the front
page there these are the terms of
reference if we turn
two please
we can see in the top third of the page
that again you are the sponsoring
executive as the executive director of
Public Health Services
and medical director
um can you tell us when this group was
established and what the purpose was for
the group
being brought into Force
um so the group was established in
August
2018. uh the story behind it is we had
conducted a review of our business
continuity Arrangements in 2016.
and that review had recommended that we
should bring together our business
continuity and emergency planning
Arrangements under the leadership of a
single executive they were at that time
under different Executives within Public
Health Wales
uh it also recommended that we should
establish
um the role of the business continuity
sorry the executive the emergency
planning and business continuity lead
the manager that I have already uh
referred to yes so um all of that uh was
accepted in 2017 and in 2017 we brought
uh started to bring these uh all
entities uh together and that was
finally completed and formalized in uh
the first half of uh 2018. if we look at
the bottom part of this page we can see
that Under The Heading updates and
amendments that there is a a blank table
has this document these terms of
reference ever been updated or amended
uh
I don't know the answer to that question
to the current time all right well it
to establish the the answer for that
then then we will formally ask
but is it right that the emergency
planning and business continuity team
was steered by the local resilience
forum
yeah
the um
the emergency
planning and business continuity team
uh effectively provided the operational
leadership uh for the implementation of
the emergency
preparedness planning and response
Arrangements of Public Health Wales and
that necessitated engagement with a wide
range of Partners Welsh government local
government the health boards the local
resilience fora
well let's look at the emergency
planning and business continuity work
plan please 2018 to 2020 which we can
see at one eight three five two three
was this document the work plan for the
group
it was and you sponsored this document
as well didn't you I did
which was approved in July of 2019 could
we look at page two please
thank you we can see at the top that the
document outlines the emergency planning
and business continuity actions for the
time period the actions address the
legal requirements on public health
whales in its role as the category one
responder and can we go to page nine
please
we can see that this sets out the
emergency planning activity under the
integrated emergency management system
and if we could just scroll through the
next few pages we can see that there are
the six phases that we've seen before
thank you if we can carry on
ending with next page please
response and Recovery
there are no references to pandemic or
influenza in this document although
there are references to bomb threats and
brexit health and and other such matters
agree with that
I do agree with that why were references
to the threats of or hazards of pandemic
influenza and matters of that nature not
contained within this document
foreign
thank you
please this is
indeed yes thank you very much we can
take that down
now dealing with your profession
two thousand
Law Firm Thompson
in May of 2011
minutes
September
changed
you
not been present
was a significant
so when
a pan
uh in the run up to exercise cygnus with
the briefing I can't wish officially it
was but describe the fact that there was
a request for an exercise and for my
attention
deputy
did you
no it wasn't the focus of my role as
Deputy Minister for health well
it must have been a focus but did you
know no because pandemic preparedness
were arrested with a cabinet minister of
Health at the time Myra was very much on
it's described now no and becoming
minister
for you to become aware of the pandemic
threat
so when I became the minister uh the
cabinet minister I received the briefing
uh which did mention uh pandemic
preparedness but there wasn't an
in-depth briefing
um and it was uh in the Run
the sickness exercise
um that I was um much better informed
um about the preparation for a pandemic
and indeed the potential scale of it and
it's
the time
and I I'd seen it and read my initial
briefing obviously but not in the way
it's now described in the tier one risk
register it would be wrong for me to try
to tell you
for sickness so what did you know of it
in May of 2016 what did you know
I knew that it was a potential risk
Pacifica
tier one
newly appointed cabinet secretary for
help
what was the most pressing health risk
to Wales
describe the fact there was work on
pressing
I think describes if the
and
it was a tier one risk
uh
guidance and document
Ary so far
plans that were in Force at the time
dealing with civil emergency
the post when did you read them
uh I've read some of them for the first
Ferry because as a minister
the overall system is prepared I did
obviously receive briefings on our
pandemic Paradise from cygnus onwards at
various points
in the Dawkins fourth inquiry
speak very quickly and we
okay I have to
thank you the
the United Kingdom influence
2011.
in a statement when did you first read
it
first you were in
I've received briefings on the strategy
in advance of cygnus and indeed
briefings on our own strategies in Wales
to try to improve
time in office that the Welsh government
managing major infectious
it's aware of it in as far as I was
briefed of it but as I say that document
isn't written for ministers to run
through and to read through and I think
it's part of
choices are required to make
add all of those documents
then I wouldn't get to do anything else
of the
document
yeah and that that forms part of the
and so it's set out
of the pandem
this was
another question whether those planning
assumptions
pandemic was the most likely of the
pandemic
uh and in terms of what was tolerable I
think that comes into some of the things
we went through in sickness and some of
the follow-on work and then
in the covert pandemic
awareness and response guidance
things
the requirement
then come to me in the briefing
or in office
thing to that
stop the spread of the pandemic
influenza virus in the country of origin
or in the UK as it will spread too
rapidly and too widely
that's the planet
the
it was already
yeah in
before
this is that that was a flawed Doctrine
to
to influenza wood spread
of
relation
number of people that
was a flaw
already
cells and days
have
quarantining or or indeed
have a night
and
having people around
created
it's around quarantine
on quarantine I've heard the evidence of
Dr Sun Sanderford this
particularly some of the localized
outbreaks we had that quarantining and
family or Community groups was entirely
possible but not at the scale that was
envisaged and there was not a
scale or the
wasn't then a consideration
common
in terms of
scale
to deal with
a level of knowledge
um did you as Minister for Health
commission any research advisory papers
or
the
to set
thank you
uh
hindsight there are good reasons to
question and to look afresh at what we
do but but nothing in the briefings that
you receive
further
it's Gathering to take place it
work out what Wales needed to do to
mitigate this threat
the way our system is
what's provided and at the time I had no
reason to go on to want to go behind it
or to question
in January of 2020.
uh
in the
China
my impression of the plan as a
or knowledge of pandemic preparedness
for the people you've already
Republican
since it is a lay perspective
describing yourself as having no
previous experience or knowledge of
pandemic preparedness when you'd been
four years in post
um
general population has certainly had
more
distinction rather than
advice
Wells I'd have a regular meeting
normally at least monthly with the chief
medical officer sometime soon
I probably see them
and so
on investing in our genome
to do so
I knew who robbed
no I wonder that of that specifically no
does that surprise you
everyone
Office of the Welsh government risk
of the health and
yes
and there was raised with
you
what time
in the course of
so actually until that
with respect I think the evidence of Mr
Hunt confirms that
as a devolved minister with any of the
UK ministers at the time
because there was a choice
it will take months to answer
one of the
week
they had an effect I think they would
have been better if we had had some form
of ministerial engagement Beyond
I don't think
I did
deliberately contacted you or avoided
your treasure you would disrespect what
he said was there was a difficult
political relationship
um
just
number of issues we didn't write every
week it wasn't we'll write a letter and
see if we get
issues we did not get
a very long
you were starting
with someone you know
but there were there were good
relationships between officials even if
they
honors most of us would like to think
they would try to get on
um
wait you see
this
decision making
foreign
two balls
and for Health and Social care and so
it did mean that other issues
um antimicrobial resistance for example
or occasional attention
change the bet
Limited
this would
as well as the
question on
balance to strike so
at the end of 20
.
but it
not just for people
your
s is
foreign
your time in office were you aware
it's exercise
but no I wasn't aware and of course 2009
was before I was elected yes I
understand
not
in plumbing term
to me in terms of
a long-term plan for Health and Social
care but
of pandemic preparedness and planning
the
aware of that exercise at the time
uh yes I
only
recommendations that this inquiry has
heard
capacity
to
um the the likes of a of a
emergency plans in place
in relation to the pandemic the
as the deaf
answers of care
together but that's not
whilst you were in the role of Deputy
Minister for health were you aware of
that was a
happy exercise
um
um in which surge capacity wasn't tested
but was mentioned that's not something
that was on your radar as Deputy Health
minister
no and essentially my
Target
doing all of the
with it
ah there's a deputy Health Minister
you don't mention exercise Alice in your
witness statement which we know was
delivered
well
cabinet Ministry
so when I became
taken place
exercise
or exercise cygnus in later on in 2016.
Texas
like
from the same
exercise
then actually so forget
challenge that you're trying to
understand and run an exercise for
did you have any direct
uh also
or the range of
with
said it was run from
him
carried forwards and in court
Dynamic planning
I understood there would be lessons
learning there would be
[Music]
um
implementation
I assumed
that the lessons of exercise cygnus
do you read
I can't recall
briefing I received from
so this is the report following the two
date or three day exercise in October of
twenty
of three please
under key learning thank you the
analysis of the evaluation reports from
the organizations participating the
exercise indicate that the UK's command
and control and emergency response
struck
pays preparedness on
this plan
demands
remember reading that in October of
2016. no
had you read it would that of course
produced
but when whenever if I had
I almost
place
learning from that about
again I made the point here about where
Minister's time is
small questions and ask
and we take it that you didn't read
didn't I did not read this
advice
there were real concerns about the
capacity of the United Kingdom
preparedness and
and you've got the documents that there
was
happening to be applied
is on the progress of those
um during 2017
around
well I I'm
uh you'll know that at various points I
have asked about follow-up from
different parts of the sector and I know
you've also been through for example the
Improvement
um the investment in microbiology a
range of other things that happened so
there were different decisions that I
made
uh
looking back I think it is fair to
if I had put
well
so
yes I've set out
arrested
um fairly significant time and then
through the rest of that period in not
just having
the long-term plan to cover both Health
and Social care but actually direct time
with
food sector together
you can't have a long-term future for
the Health Service without social care
being part of the answer
advisors bring to your attention that as
part of
expressed
late and accurate picture of social care
capacity because much of the capacity
Lay With Private providers
not specifically in those terms but I'm
mostly aware of the structure
two decades
something that
is
in the meantime is is that a concern
Mr for help
not in those specific terms like I said
the concerns about social
endemic
did you cause
a result of what you
problems with
yes we invested in Social care it was
part of our
I made deliberate choices to put parts
of the NHS allocated budget into
partnership space that had to be used by
health
seven retail partnership boards that we
created so social care was definitely
part of what we were concerned about and
wanted to invest in its future
the
in the sector
who the new actors are going to be there
are lots of relatively small
ability if people retire
not be able to carry on so so that was a
challenge and the way
we risk
challenges in the way I've describing
would still exist now
but we're in a better position now than
when I started and I expect we'll be in
a better position
it's part of our success story that a
lot of us can expect to live to be older
and there's
did you take any action on this
recurring issue
no register
homes
or for any sort of out
free
things uh
papers were you aware that during a
meeting of that group and the following
was discussed adult social care and
Community Health Care NR advised that
there was currently an issue around who
would be the SRO for the social care
work stream within the department
trying to establish
or social care capacity but the task was
extremely difficult as most of the care
pro
I was a re-statement of the problem
knowledge of of private social care yeah
part of what you're
commit
to the 22.
of
able to
sir Frank Everton
about the
passed to ministers according to Mr
Atherton along
it might have been mystical path
a chain I think referred to during the
evidence of Mr Everton which indicated
that this concern needed to be brought
to the attention of ministers
yes was that brought to you
I know the revenue
there are
fish
sounds like
waiting for the Department of Health
and review its own plans and guidance do
you consider to that that to be a
problem for Wales
it's always part of the challenge when
you want to work across the the four
nations about where and how you
do in Wales whereas in
do it
things differently
block within the UK and it's likely that
if you
the reality travel buttons and
population size that you would want to
have that comes through so
again
put in front of me as a minister
I would and it goes back to I think
um
I want to know what has happened within
a certain time
lots of people
all right
a minute
you have correspondences
which
way
so
that we could have
and so actually that's
an understanding about the average
or granular detail to understand with
numbers of
action prevention
in general
right
thank you
[Music]
support
great deal about
stop
what
in price
most of our
resilient in the future we would need to
carry on investing in people
and the challenge there
the four nations of the UK
they're a political and financial
choices that come with them if you want
to invest in having a supply that you
know is more expensive and you could buy
in another part of the world but you're
doing it because you want to make sure
you don't have fragility if there's a
future pandemic you've got to be
prepared to do that and that has a
budget consequence too it's the same
with other areas of
you know I have looked at Mr Hunt's
evidence and he talks about South Korea
so not just on PPE but on improving
capacity in Laboratories for example
well that isn't just the capital
involved in building a facility you need
the people to do that and you've got to
invest on a recurrent basis
and
that
to you
improving capacity in Laboratories for
example well that isn't just the capital
involved in building a facility you need
the people to do that and you've got to
invest on a recurrent basis for that to
happen
so those are choices and
that resilience if you're looking to
build it in if you need more capacity
you can't avoid the fact that will cost
more money and that's a choice we have
to prepare collectively
to make
um and I think that holds regardless of
who's in government in whichever part of
the UK
were you aware that Welsh and uk-wide
planning assumptions were to plan for
successive flu waves to each last
approximately 15 weeks in duration yes
I'd like to just look please at the
document which sets out the
stockpile held in South Wales of PPE
it's at 66526 and just reminding
ourselves that the central PPE stockpile
for Wales was the pandemic influenza
preparedness program stockpile and we
this is audit Wales report entitled
procuring and supplying PPE for the
covid-19 pandemic it's dated April of
2021. now this will be the subject of
evidence in later modules but I'd just
like to look please at page 21 and
paragraph 1.26
to to ask you about the planning and
whether or not it was sufficient and can
we highlight please the table in the
middle of the page yeah this is the
quantity of items in the pipp stockpile
as we've just established in March 2020
and how long it lasted
aprons
six weeks eye protectors 10 weeks type
2R masks which are of particular use for
Care Homes and hospitals 5.5 weeks ffp3
respirators 10.9 weeks gloves singles
1.5 weeks hand sanitizer 4.3 weeks
it even
if we acknowledge that the assumptions
that the Welsh and UK government were
planning for were not strictly adhered
to by the covid-19 pandemic
in fact in some senses they were worse
weren't they
do you agree that the PPE stockpile in
Wales was woefully inadequate to deal
with
the pandemic that was being planned for
yes so our Collective planning
assumptions did not stand up against
reality so they were not adequate for
the challenge we then faced and that is
set out in the table
um I think it's very very clear I don't
think with respect sorry to interrupt
that wasn't the question because the
question was the planning was for
something that was going to last 15
weeks yes and the point Miss Black was
making is that it didn't even last the
15 weeks not just covered no and that
was and I remember having a conversation
about this time I want to try to avoid
going too far into the actual response
we were going through PPE at a much
faster rate than our planning ourselves
and assumed reward so actually we found
that our stockpile that should have
blasted for a whole wave didn't
uh and you know the rate at which we're
going through it was much faster than we
expected and it's why in the very early
stages this was one of my major concerns
in practice but I I don't get
drawn too far into what I know will be
going through in module two
you agree Mr gethin
place
plan for the wrong pandemic
but it was an inadequate plan in any
event even for the pandemic that it was
being
created for
I think it's fair to say that the plan
for an influenza pandemic would still
have had challenges if we'd had an
influenza pandemic
um
I hesitate to say it was inadequate
because it's such a loaded term but it
certainly with all the evidence that
I've seen I know the inquiry scene
planning for an influenza type pandemic
was not complete and we would have had
vulnerabilities if it had been an
influenza panda thank you
my lady those are all the questions I
have for Mr gething you have
provisionally provided permission for a
series of questions all to be asked by
covid-19 bereaved families for justice
Camry
please may that be done now
they do the shepherd Mr gething my name
is Laura Shepard and I appear on behalf
of covid-19 three families for justice
company
I'm going to start off by asking you
about stakeholders I don't know if you
heard the evidence of rose mcgallagher
that she gave last week she spoke about
the engagement or perhaps lack thereof
that she had with the UK government
did you as health Minister invite to the
Royal College of Nursing or the British
Medical Association or any other
clinical stakeholder groups to have
input into the Welsh government's
pandemic planning
no I didn't ask for all colleges to take
part specifically
in the
in the way that pandemic planning was
undertaken you've had this evidence from
a range of people
officials within the Welsh government
worked with a range of Partners but I'm
I'm not sure whether they did engage
with royal colleges or not
and I didn't see Rose mcgallick as
evidence on this point
were you aware that in her report in
2011 Dame Deidre Hein this was following
the swine flu pandemic she advised us to
increase stakeholder engagement in
pandemic planning
uh yes I'm aware of that in preparation
for this inquiry I'm not sure if she
defined the list of stakeholders but I'm
aware that it was one of the
recommendations
I'm going to move on now to ask you
about surge capacity
um
so um you've been asked questions about
the sufficiency of the PPE stockpile uh
and I know that you heard the evidence
that was given earlier
um by um Andrew Goodall and he spoke
about the work stream that was in place
as to Surge capacity and how that wasn't
finalized before January 2020.
when it got to the pandemic do you agree
that there was a difficulty with surge
capacity in Wales
yes it was a difficult circum capacity
in Wales as in the rest of the UK and
the challenges during The Surge capacity
it's not just a facility it's people you
need
um
and that is the Big Challenge so if if
you can invest in more people you have
more capacity to search to but those
people will be working before you need
to change things so the ability to Surge
is about people it's partly about
facilities it's also and I think I went
through this briefly in questions
earlier
you have to choose what you're not going
to do to create that space
whether that's
the number of people
who you would then expect to provide
care to give you more capacity or
whether it is stopping
some services from happening or
reorganizing the way that they do
for those choices made in preparation or
were they made at the time when covert
hit
so some of that work had been done in
preparation I know you heard from this
from Dr Goodall the work hadn't been
concluded but the thinking about it was
not starting from a zero base
the challenge then is when it happens
you have to think very quickly that's
why the work stream on regulation is
relevant as well
because part of that surge capacity was
a change in regulation that was swiftly
introduced and was envisaged actually in
terms of pandemic for parents
to allow to have people put back on the
professional registers to undertake
work they wouldn't otherwise have done
and that of course relies on those
people wanting and being prepared to
come forward so
I guess fair to say that the work wasn't
complete but it doesn't mean that
nothing had happened because when the
time came
there was thinking to rely on as well as
the need to make choices
um I just want to have a look at some of
the planning presumptions when it comes
to Surge capacity if we could have up on
the screen please eight nine five seven
three uh this is a document you've
already been referred to today this is
the Wales Health and Social care
influenza pandemic preparedness and
response guidance stated February 2014
if we could have a look at page seven
please
so in the box there in the middle of the
page the very top
um
the very top row in that box says up to
50 percent of the population could
experience symptoms of pandemic
influenza over one or more pandemic
waves each lasting 15 weeks
and then if we look a couple of boxes
down it says one to four percent of
symptomatic people may require hospital
treatment
so that's up to two percent of the
entire population of Wales in hospital
potentially in a 15-week period was
Wales prepared for that
not in the sense we had the hospital
capacity of the staff of the pandemic
that's a simple matter of the maths of
the matter
to be prepared to know that you might
have to do that
in general terms we didn't have a
granular plan on here is how we will
create that capacity I think it's also
fair to point out the Shepherd that the
planning of subsider on the reasonable
worst case scenario so that is if you're
not taking action
and actually of course we did act and
the assumptions are these things can
happen if you don't take action
what we did meant that 42 of the
population did not require hospital
treatment and to create the capacity for
that
um
again I try not to get drawn into model
tumor lady but of course we did have to
rapidly go through some of the
challenges around field Hospital
expansion um
I'm going to move on now then to access
deaths and what I mean by this is the
measures in place to deal with that body
bags Mortuary capacity and the ability
to maintain the Dignity of those who
died
um according to your Welsh government
document from the technical Advisory
Group there were 2 257 deaths involving
covid-19 between the 1st of March 2020
and the 31st of May 2020. so that's a
period of 12 weeks Wales was not
prepared for that number of deaths was
it
I think
in terms of the The Briefing that I had
excess deaths were mentioned I was aware
there was work on excess deaths that
needed to be completed
um I don't think that work was finalized
the most difficult part I think is not
the physical capacity
it's the dignity and death that I found
most
um
difficult
if we could have a look again please at
the um the 89573 document page seven
again we've got excess deaths below the
table on page seven
and again it says here planners should
aim to be able to cope with between
twelve thousand and fifteen thousand
deaths in Wales
and that's over a 15-week period we had
just over 2 000 deaths in Wales over 12
week period
do you accept that lack of preparation
led to real pain and suffering of the
bereaved in Wales
I think
in honesty
addressing the issue of excess
deaths does lead to pain and suffering
and it did lead to it because as I say
one of the things I found most difficult
was the dignity and death
and
knowing what a bad death is
an understanding that that has a real
impact on people who are left behind
and when we started
and had to consider the measures we
might have to take immediately
for more tree capacity and for
crematoria and I knew the Crematory
capacity and there were plans that had
gone through
been discussed with Partners about how
to increase Crematory capacity but
actually
all of this work was not fully completed
and that meant that when covid came
we were not as prepared as we could and
should have been
and that does yes the shepherd lead to
additional pain for bereaved families
and do you accept that you had
responsibility to plan for that
yes I'm a minister in the government of
course it's my responsibility this one
final area I wanted to ask you about and
that was infection control and in
particular isolation rooms in hospitals
the evidence that we heard earlier today
from Dr Sanderson and we also heard it
yesterday was there was no provision in
Wells whatsoever to deal with hcids
which means that if people in Wales if
someone else has a hcid they're taken to
London or
I think it's Newcastle
do you accept that lack of preparedness
for even one case of SARS in Wales
reflects a big oversight from those who
are responsible for pandemic
preparedness no
and I think the reason is important
so if you have two centers in England
you're dealing with very small numbers
of a high consequence uh infection
um
the challenge we'll look at is how do we
make sure we have the ability with a
small number of high consequence
infections for the scale of the pandemic
the centers in London and Newcastle
could not cope
and would not reasonably cope actually
the challenges around how you surge
capacity as we had to with intensive
care and more is much more relevant to
pandemic preparedness and coping with a
genuine pandemic as we did in the early
stages of containment
um
and I think Chris which has given
evidence on this as well I don't think
it would have made any difference if
we'd had a center in Wales if that had
been in the heath and Cardiff
if you live in better secured that
wouldn't have been the place you would
have gone anyway
um so there's a challenge about
understanding the difference between a
very small number of high consequence
infections if you if you recall when
there was a nurse who returned from the
work she was doing and any of the
challenge around Ebola
actually that is where you have those
very limited number of high consequence
um facilities
the pandemic is a different order
SARS was a hcid until March 2020 and
there was not sorry coronavirus and SARS
was
um uh hcid until March 2020 and there
was not one single isolation unit in
Wales that could deal with it was there
not not at that time no and as I say
in terms of I think we're maybe talking
a different points here having an
individual unit with a small number of
beds would not have prevented the
challenges of the pandemic the scale and
the depth of what we needed to prepare
for and to deal with would not have been
changed if we'd had four high
consequence infection beds at University
Hospital Wales in Cardiff
and that's the point I'm trying to I
think there's a danger
that you say this is the issue and
actually it's the much broader
challenges of preparedness I think that
are the real challenge
thank you my lady
thank you very much for Shepherd I
ladies
to get things evidence thank you very
much for your help together thank you
and would that be a convenient moment to
take our afternoon break before the
Final witness of the day yes of course
um
to try to think it's very important
obviously we finished Mr drakeford's
evidence today perhaps 10 minutes
I'm sorry you're getting mixed messages
I am getting mixed messages at 10
minutes
foreign
Mr Keith
the first minister of Wales please
I do solemnly
seem sincerely and truly
declare and affirm
that the evidence I shall give
shall be the truth
the whole truth
but nothing but the truth
cute
would you be good enough to give your
full name please to the inquiry Mark
Drakeford
Drakeford thank you very much for the
assistance that you have so far provided
to the inquiry by way of the provision
of a witness statement
is that a witness statement
dated the 21st of April 2023 to which
you've appended your signature and
declared the statement of Truth
it is
Mr Draper whilst you give evidence could
you please keep your voice up whilst at
the same time not falling into the Trap
into which a number of other Witnesses
have fallen of speaking too fast for our
stenographer
Mr Drakeford it is very well known
that you are the first minister of Wales
and you have been so since December of
2018 but before that from March 2013
were you Minister for Health and Social
Services and from May 16 cabinet
secretary for finance and local
government and then November 17 cabinet
secretary for finance
I was
your experience
therefore reflects or or is important
for a number of areas in this module
because in practice you've worked inside
and and of course you now lead the Welsh
government
since the outset of devolution
and you've worked as both Health
Minister and Minister for local
government and therefore you have great
experience of
with
the system for health emergencies as
well as of course the resourcing
for the preparedness structures in in
Wales
did you also have to deal with the Ebola
outbreak whilst you're a health minister
that didn't happen while I was the
health Minister yes and you may indeed
even have been an advisor in government
at the time of the swine flu pandemic
before that that's true
all right
I'd like to start ask you asking you
questions please about
Devolution and and the position
concerning civil contingencies
you are of course familiar with the
Welsh ministers transfer of functions
order 2018.
that is a
a hugely important piece of legislation
secondary legislation which came into
force on the 24th of May 2018.
and it transferred functions from
Ministers of the crown
in in London
to Welsh government ministers
in relation to the field of civil
contingencies as well as I should say a
number of a large number of other
matters is that broadly correct that is
correct
so that we can understand the position
prior to that date
were there a number of functions
activities executive functions which
were already within the competence of
the Welsh government that is to say that
they were not reserved they were
devolved matters
but they had not practically been
transferred to the Welsh government
enabling you to be able to carry them
out
well the Welsh government had been
involved in dealing with civil
emergencies from the very start of the
evolution the very first year I was part
of advising the Welsh government we had
a series of events in flooding
in our fuel protests and foot and mouth
disease which Illustrated that in fact
if not in law the Welsh government was
drawn into responding to those civil
emergencies and that continued to be the
case uh in the decade and more
thereafter
but legally some of the functions which
you were required obligated to carry out
wouldn't or were on one view still
Reserve matters which had not been
converted into devolved matters enabling
you to act legally or were matters which
had been changed into devolved matters
but but the piece of secondary
legislation formally confirming that
there were powers that you could
exercise hadn't yet gone through but you
just got on with the job
in many ways to transfer functions or to
regularized the way in which things had
happened on the ground for some time
an important part of that order
concerned part one of the Civil
contingencies act 2004 the United
Kingdom legislation concerned with civil
contingencies because until the order
was made transferring functions from
Ministers of the crown to the Welsh
ministers
the Welsh government was unable to pass
regulations under that act and also
formally to discharge the functions
specified by the act itself it is that
broadly correct that is correct here
there's evidence before Melody's inquiry
that until the transfer of functions
order
much of the
discharge of civil contingencies Powers
by the Welsh government
was therefore framed not by
that legislative framework or the
legality of the the functions order
but by the views of the first ministers
in place at the time and and Senior
Welsh ministers you were in other words
forced back onto the
in into the position of of making
decisions yourselves as ministers as
executive
ministerial
decision makers
regardless of the legal position and the
application of the Civil contingencies
act would you agree
um
only in part I think because many of the
emergencies which were dealt with over
that period relied on other powers which
were already in the hands of Welsh
ministers
so I could give you one example while I
was the health Minister there was a
major measles outbreak in South Wales it
was a public health emergency but all
the powers that we needed to respond to
that were already in the hands of Welsh
ministers through the public health Act
of 1984.
presumably
in anticipation of
the transfer of functions order being
made and it was an order which you had
sought of course politically the Welsh
government
had for some time stated to the United
Kingdom government it is time for these
functions to be transferred let us make
de jure what is already de facto
presumably you had to make sure that the
Welsh government structures in terms of
resourcing
personnel the group or committee
structure was ready to discharge the new
functions which it would be allowed to
carry out
well the normal pattern would be that
the transfer of functions is accompanied
by a transfer of funding to discharge
those functions because those functions
are already being discharged elsewhere
so you no longer need to transfer to
discharge them at central government
level and the funding follows so it
would be true that the Welsh government
was responsible for making sure that in
terms of structures that we were ready
to discharge those new responsibilities
uh in this case as I think inquiry will
know no funding followed from the UK
government for these purposes so funding
had to be found from within why do wash
government resources that would
otherwise have been used for other
purposes
so looking at those three areas of
resources personnel and the structure in
terms of resources the Welsh government
was keep me aware that it would need
extra resources in order to discharge
the additional functions
which it was empowered to operate or
would be empowered to operate from May
2018. did you see you seek from the
United Kingdom government additional
resources to enable you to carry out
those new functions yes
and what was the response Carbondale
office said that they had been unable to
identify any expenditure that they had
undertaken to discharge those functions
and therefore there was no money to be
transferred
they could not identify any discrete
sums of money used for those purposes in
Wales
therefore there was no sum of money that
they could identify to a company the
transfer of responsibilities
so in effect because they were unable to
specify how much the existing discharge
of those functions cost them
in the general Kitty perhaps the general
Consolidated fund
they would not give you and could not
give you the same amount of money in
order for you to then discharge those
functions going forward that was their
argument
and therefore you you fell back of
course on your own
funding sources
we did we employed eight new or we
created eight new posts within the Welsh
government to enable us to discharge
these new responsibilities but they were
funded as I said not from the new money
that you might have expected but from
money that was already
devolved to Wales for the functions that
was government already possessed
may we take it from the fact that
post-covid
the relevant
risk and resilience
directorate or division has many more
people now in it than was the case in
that the number of people you were able
to fund
fell short of of
use a word from earlier in the evidence
the optimum it you would all other
things being equal had you had the money
preferred to fund considerably more
people than the age that you were able
to do so
well my experience as Finance Minister
taught me that you always had to think
of two things you had to think of the
amount of money that you have available
but you also have to think about the
capacity of a system to absorb that
funding
sometimes it's not just a matter of
finding the money systems can't spend
the money you can't spend the money
wisely if you
provide it all too quickly capacity has
to be built up over time and in the
beginning 8 posts to take on these new
responsibilities I felt as the Finance
Minister having to find the money uh
that that was both something we could
manage financially but also that the
system would be able to use that money
in a proper way
let me ask you the same question in a
different way Mr Drakeford had the
United Kingdom government provided the
funding that you had sought would you
have still ended up with only eight
people in that team
very hard question to to be sure given
that they didn't give us any money at
all uh we would have cut our code to
code into our class all right
in terms of personnel
it wasn't just a question then of being
able to identify
changes in Personnel in the particular
part of the Welsh government the Welsh
government resilience team perhaps
what consideration was given to ensuring
that for the discharge across the board
of these civil contingencies powers
more people would need to be placed in
various other parts of the Welsh
government or outside the Welsh
government either in relation to the
audit teams or the local resilience
Forum level or the Strategic
coordinating group level and so on
I think my recollection of the tongue is
that the powers were more about allowing
resources that were already there to be
deployed more effectively uh I I'm not
saying for a moment that there was no
case for additional resources but the
primary case was you have a resource the
powers that they need are not in the
right place when those powers are
transferred those people who are there
already will be able to do their job
more effectively
and finally in relation to the structure
there was a pre-existing civil
contingency structure in Wales of course
and as we'll see later in the course of
your evidence it had many moving parts
to what extent did the Welsh government
seek to recalibrate that structure to
make sure that the structure was in the
best place possible to start carrying
out the new functions which the transfer
of functions order permitted them to do
so
well ministerially because that's the
perspective from which I was able to
view it are the structures were
sufficient to make sure a device flowed
to ministers flowed in a timely way was
enabled to raise issues with ministers
when those issues were required and in
some ways you don't spend your time
looking at the wiring diagram so long as
you are confident that the diagram
produces the result that you need
consistent advice of the quality that
you require in a timely fashion and uh I
felt confident the system did do that
Beyond I don't mean this pejoratively
beyond the parochial issue of what
advice
individual ministers in the first
ministers
the first Minister was receiving
to what extent did the Welsh government
stand back and say is this structure for
civil contingencies emergency
preparedness the correct structure to be
able to deal with
the future discharge of these additional
powers and yes the evidence is quite
plain that there are a lot of different
bodies in the Welsh contingencies field
were they the right bodies in the right
place to be able to deal with these new
functions well my predecessor as first
Minister ordered a review of those
structures to accompany the transfer of
functions uh so there was a conscious
effort to make sure that the Welsh
government would be equipped in a
structural sense to use the new powers
that came its way
there was and the ladies had evidence to
this effect a report on civil
emergencies in Wales dated the 6th of
December 2012. there's there's
absolutely no reason why you would have
had to have had that brought to your
attention when you became first minister
or even
Health Minister because it was before
your tenure as health minister
but the evidence um yesterday and and in
part today is that that report in 2012
highlighted the fact that there were too
many bodies too many groups in the Civil
contingency system in Wales that there
was a complex resilience framework
problems with inefficiency and
effectiveness
as well as there be no common approach
to risk assessment and a number of other
important matters
do you know whether or not following
that report in 2012 six years before the
transfer of functions order
there was any rationalization of the
groups or the structures
well I've given some this some thought
having herded rays in previous with
previous Witnesses
from the perspective of the minister
the system did not look particularly
complex
you know there was I think it's to be
found in the pan Wheels response plan on
a single page
the essence of the the structure once
the structure moves into the
particularities of you know professional
roles and perspectives it does sometimes
enter rather an Arcane world that is
only really understood by those who are
part of it but as a minister what I
needed to know was how would advice get
to me
which levels would it have passed
through am I confident that means that
the advice that comes onto my desk has
been tested as the necessary expertise
and I didn't feel that complexity uh was
a barrier to that happening
we're going to try to find that diagram
Mr jakeford if we can I think pan Wales
response plan
107.119 yes
I don't have you can find it on page
nine on page nine on page 11 goes
alongside that
yeah so there is the the flowchart
which which deals in fact with a
slightly different issue which is the
levels
of contingency or emergency because in
the event of a level two
the Civil contingencies group is
required to establish a Wales civil
contingencies committee
so I think what you have in mind is
perhaps rather more page 11 which is a
concentric chart
now that's um that's again dealing with
levels one two and three we'll see if we
can find it but I I think you have in
mind there is a concentric chart which
sets out the local resilience forums the
Strategic coordinating groups the
various external bodies and then those
parts of the Welsh government on top but
essentially from The Minister's point of
view provided all of that is effectively
translated into the actions that you
would need to take in face of an
emergency are set out on pages nine and
eleven then you have confidence to know
that the system when called upon
whatever complexity you might like
behind it the system uncalled upon will
operate in that comprehensible way
would you nevertheless agree that
following the 2012 Civil emergencies
report the audit office report on civil
emergencies in Wales
between that time and 2018 there was no
wholesale
change or no significant change to the
Civil contingency structure in Wales
yeah I think that'll be all right in May
exactly concurrent in fact the transfer
of functions order
there was a report of internal audit
services
called audit Services emergency planning
preparedness and response 128972
which was concerned with the Assurance
rating of the emergency planning
preparedness and response system
so it's a report by internal audit
services within the Welsh government
if you look at the top half of the page
you will see an over arching General
Assurance rating given
to the system of emergency planning
preparedness and response and and quite
evidently
Mr jayford all parts of the Welsh
government are subject award debted
at some level and from time to time and
this is the audit on emergency planning
preparation response the Assurance
rating is given as reasonable
if you take it from me that that was a
reduction in the rating from the earlier
rating which was substantial that it had
received eight years before in 2010.
were you aware that at the time that the
functions were being transferred to the
Welsh government the Assurance rating
for the Welsh government's emergency
planning system had been downgraded one
slot one mark
I don't think that I would have known it
in those terms what I would have been
aware of was advice
suggested that the level of threat over
that period had grown
so that the system itself
may have been as it was in 2012 but now
it's having to deal with different
threats and more significant threats
there are
references in this report to prospective
obligations which would have to be
placed on the first minister of Wales
you weren't first Minister then you
became so in December of 2018 but if you
could have page three paragraphs 1.3
through to 1.6 page 3 1.3 to 1.6
perhaps picking up the thread at 1.5
following a Wells audit report in 2012
the first Minister has has agreed to the
transfer exec of executive functions
this is likely to take place by June
2018.
this gives Welsh ministers brand new
powers to exercise additional functions
including issuing guidance
monitoring default responders and
require them to produce information
bringing enforcement proceedings
and then if we could just run through
please to page five at paragraph 3.7 so
that we can see the overarching scheme
page five paragraph 3.7
resource requirements have been
identified by the Brazilians team to be
able to carry out the new duties and
activities required to support ministers
responsibilities and there's a reference
then to the then first Minister writing
to the United Kingdom government looking
for money
in Broad terms Mr Drakeford following
that audit report
which had noted that the rating had
reduced itself from substantial to
reasonable
was there a wholesale rewriting of
guidance were in a general sense the
Welsh government's pandemic plans and
civil contingencies plans Rewritten
were there or was there put into place a
new system or an enhanced system of
monitoring divorce responders and
possibly bringing enforcement
proceedings
the system didn't have a wholesale
change and the review that my
predecessor
said in Motion in 2016 concluded that
wholesale change was not required they
were adoptions and they were
modifications but the system did not
need a routine branch
uh rewriting in the in the terms that
you put it as you know the powers that
came with the transfer functions order
were not exercised immediately
On a related issue
the Welsh government had never produced
its own self-standing risk assessment
process or risk assessment
document setting out all the risks
facing the Welsh government in the same
way that the United Kingdom government
did in London and were aware that the
Scottish government did in Scotland
do you recall whether at this time of
great change
consideration was given
to the production and publication for
the first time of a Welsh Centric risk
assessment process
I don't think I could say to your own
brother a specific discussion of that
sort I remember the general discussion
which is that for certain purposes it is
sensible from a Welsh perspective to lie
on to rely on the expertise and the
capacity that the UK government has and
we were content at this point to do so
I'm not sure we would have felt that
there was a huge advantage to be gained
from
deducing Welsh specific risks when the
UK government's risk assessment process
appeared to us to be one that you could
rely on and have the expertise it
required to deliver it
you are of course familiar with the
doctrine that all risk is local the
subsidiarity principle
you've no doubt seen the evidence about
how the Civil contingencies field the
principle of subsidiary subsidiarity is
applied there will no doubt be risks
which will affect Wales differently
there may even be risks which would only
affect Wales but to rely upon the United
Kingdom risk register for risks
identified by UK officials to apply
across the board
tended did it not to
um
fail to give sufficient consideration to
Welsh specific risks and how they might
be managed well the way that that was
discharged was through the four lrfs so
I agree with you that you need a lookup
application of the national register
whether there is a Welsh intermediate
tier for that or something we did not
feel at that time would have Justified
the resources that would have been
required to develop it but we did ensure
that at the 4lrf levels there was a
statutory obligation to produce a
community risk register
so if I might just give you one example
the national risk register no doubt had
things in it about what happened in the
event of an explosion at an oil refinery
now in the David Powers part of Wales
that's a significant concern given that
there's a concentration of oil
refineries in the north of Wales that
wouldn't be
very high consideration there being no
oil refineries actually across the North
Wales Coast so the way in which we
discharged the obligation which I agree
with is an important one to localize and
particularize the national risk register
was not at a Wales level but at the
level of the four lrfs and that's
exactly the point isn't it that the risk
assessments were looked at solely in the
context at least formally on paper of
the local the four local resilience
forums there was no formal process by
which the national Welsh government
could identify a risk in relation to
which it may have to step into to deal
with alongside the local resilience
Forum the Strategic coordinating group
and whatever Regional partnership there
might be I think you will find that in
the and I've heard you use the word
labyrinthine structures that exist
actually there is a group which is
chaired by the Welsh government which
brings the four lrf risk assessors
together for this purpose so while it's
discharge of the lrf level the Welsh
government is not in ignorance of the
way that those Community risk
assessments are being produced because
there is a coming together of the four
lrfs under the chairing of a Welsh
government official in order to collect
that back at an all-wales from an
all-wields perspective there is a Welsh
resilience Forum of which such issues
are debated my point though Mr Drakeford
was concerned with the system of risk
assessment there is no process by which
formerly the Welsh government
gets to analyze the risks which its
country faces which may have to be
responded to not just by local
resilience forums but by the Welsh
government itself in the way that there
is for Scotland and for England not for
those purposes we use the UK Waheed risk
assessment process
in October of 2018
at one of the meetings of that exact
same body the Welsh resilience Forum Mr
drankford the
the then cabinet secretary for for local
government and public services agreed
that a review of emergency planning
governance and structures was
required
I think in order to ensure whether they
were quote fit for purpose
you agreed as first Minister because by
December you had become the first
Minister you would agree that a
comprehensive review should be
undertaken which would develop a
platform to support the new regulations
so
the answer perhaps to my one of my
earlier questions was that there was a
recognition by you on behalf of the
Welsh government but by you personally
that
it was important to carry out a review
to make sure that the system could cope
with that transfer of powers
I I think I said apologies if I glossed
over it in an earlier answer that my
predecessor on agreeing the transfer of
functions had initiated that review now
by the time it came to make its way into
sort of formal uh signing officer to
probably you've been overtaken by by my
arrival right the initiation of it
pre-pre-dated my becoming first minister
we believe that following that Welsh
resilience for a meeting which didn't
take place until October 2018.
the matter formally did go to you as
first Minister and and you agreed that
that review was necessary
the review didn't however
take place did it
until 2023. no
and so that we can understand the
chronology
it took
the best part of 2018 for that review
process to be initiated
the review was then hampered
by the diversion of resources to what is
now
by way of a familiar refrain the
necessary preparations for a No Deal EU
exit
and then of course after that covet
is it a matter of some regret that that
review which was obviously important
otherwise you wouldn't have ordered it
was not in the event able to be brought
to fruition and and was not brought to
fruition for a matter of years
there being
at least 18 months from October 18 to
March 2020.
well of course it was a matter of
considerable disappointments
to us because the Welsh government had
as you said worked hard to secure the
transfer of those responsibilities
and to make sure that we were in a
proper position to discharge them but by
the time I became first minister
I chaired my first cabinet I think four
days after becoming first Minister and
almost the whole of our cabinet uh
meeting is devoted to preparations for
leaving the European Union without a
deal so by the time I became first
Minister the system was already turning
its sights very firmly to a danger that
was right in front of you and our very
significant potential consequence
may we have please in that review
uh one eight seven five eight zero
please of 2023 there is the review of
civil contingencies in Wales
it says across it or at least on the
copy that we have Mr Drakeford in in in
in Stern terms not government policy
um
but
we have been collectively little
troubled by that this is a review of
civil contingencies in Wales ordered by
the Welsh government in part but jointly
owned by a number of other organizations
why is it necessary why is it
why does it say not government policy is
that because you haven't yet formally
decided whether or not to give effect to
its recommendations well I I am
imagining rather than being certain in
the specifics but this will be the
normal way of things happening in Wales
the document will be produced we would
wish the views of Partners
uh to be received on it they may be
aspects of it that the fire service for
example take just one example might wish
to draw to our attention so while we
would circulate the document to make
sure anybody with an interest can
contribute to the final version we make
it clear to people that it's not at that
stage formally adopted as government
policy
if we turn to page 33 please we'll find
the
recommendations priorities and next
steps
the first one is a national Assurance
framework for Wales to be developed with
monitoring to be managed by the Welsh
resilience board so in fact a new a new
body not the whilst the Wales resilience
Forum but the Wales resilience board
and in the right hand column the authors
of this worthy document state that this
is a matter that is critical
if we just go forward to page 35 we will
see what is meant by critical although
it may be thought self-evident
there we are critical do now it is of
the greatest importance that action is
taken immediately
so going back to page 33
may we take it Mr Drakeford that the
authors of this report regarded the ABS
for National Assurance framework for
Wales that is to say a system by which
all the moving Parts in the Welsh civil
contingency structure could be tested to
make sure they were up to scratch was a
matter of the very greatest concern
to which it was essential that action be
taken right away
well it is so self-evidently the views
of the authors uh that this is the most
important recommendation uh my own view
would be that nevertheless that
recommendation has to be tested by
others uh given that its implementation
will rely upon the willingness of others
to make that contribution so no doubt
this will make its way to my desk with
final proposals and they may not look
identical to the ones that we see in
front of us this afternoon the Civil
Service in in Wales will of course
present this to you along with their own
views and and no doubt seek a decision
from you
number two risk we were just debating
this very issue a few moments ago
the Welsh government and local
resilience Forum should work in
Partnership to interpret the UK National
risk register and adapt UK level risks
to Wales to identify upcoming a
potential risk that would significantly
impact Wales
essential
does that go directly to the heart of
the issue that we were debating a few
moments ago the need for a Welsh
government level input into the
identification management ownership of
Welsh risks
yes it does I was careful in answering
your earlier questions to try to be
clear that the view that the UK risk
register was adequate for the purpose
was a view of that time I was aware
because I've been involved in some
discussions through the resilience Forum
uh that contemporary thinking is that
that intermediate Welsh level may need
strengthening and you see that in this
recommendation
on page 34
at number 13
Regional risk assessment should be used
to define a Regional training and
exercise regime to address well-wide
capability gaps or development needs and
then over the page of 15 page 35
centrally managed
training and exercise regime
now
plainly
many of these recommendations
must have been
formed as a result of the terrible
experience of covid
the extent that they identify
significant changes in the Welsh
structure for civil contingencies
training Assurance formal process of
risk assessment does this not rather
indicate
that there were pre-existing structural
flaws in the Civil contingency system in
Wales
that is to say even before covert
I think I probably have two observations
to make there first of all I wouldn't
necessarily
interpret the fact that a document says
that Skittles and professional
development is needed as meaning that
that didn't exist previously
I think it is just a statement of the
ongoing need to make sure that that is
uh part of the system
and I don't think myself you can
necessarily uh conclude that because in
the light of
new powers
change circumstances uh that a report
says that
that now needs to be reflected in new
and strengthened systems that that says
that prior to those things the system
was there was not fit for the purposes
which at that time were there to be
discharged
put Mr Drakeford
the premise of that answer was that this
is recommending new and improved systems
insofar as the report recommended
a national Assurance framework
a Welsh government risk assessment
procedure
a provision of centrally managed
training and exercise those were not
improvements
they are Standalone and completely novel
developments
they simply have never existed hitherto
and they reflect the report author's
view of what is needed in Wales in 2023
rather than their reflection of what was
needed in 2018. I think that's that's
the only point I'm making is that it is
reflecting today's Wales today's
circumstances today's challenges
but these were challenges of course
which have come into Focus as a result
of covid
but in terms of the structural
performance of the Civil contingencies
structure in Wells that these are not
new issues the United Kingdom
the London government had put into
position over many years
a system for National assurance
for National resilience standards Milady
heard evidence about the the production
of three different versions of those
National resilience standards
and National resilience Academy
a structure for training and exercising
they are all part and parcel of civil
contingencies are they not
and the capacity to offer training and a
number of those things existed right
through the system they are restated
here in the contemporary
circumstances all right
risk registers
you'll know from the paperwork which we
have provided you with that
they were in existence corporate risk
registers
for the Welsh government
and
please may we have up the first one
which is an issue which is January 2016
page one column P5 or entry P5 row P5
resilience major emergencies if we fail
to provide effective leadership and
coordination and ensuring that Wells is
prepared for and resilient to the full
range of national hazards then there's a
risk to health and well-being for
Citizens a self-evident risk one might
think
there are then a list of controls
identified as being the risk control
measures or proposed mitigating actions
and if we could just go over the page
please
we'll see the
the rubric
the notes which go with
um that those scores and explain what
they all are
if you go back please to page one
there is it appears in this risk
register
very little by way of specific
identification of what
the emergency that is pandemic influenza
might consist of or the specific
controls or countermeasures for pandemic
influenza as opposed to Major
emergencies civil contingencies major
events and so on would you agree Mr
Rayford
I think that is that's a a fair summary
of what we see in front of us if we then
have a look at June 19 21558
which is a single page document
and on this occasion please feel free to
scroll in
reference to
risk description disruption event
affecting people places finances
Communications and I.T if there is a
significant disruption event the Welsh
government May struggle to recover its
operations quickly and effectively and
then
a number of mitigation measures control
measures by way of business continuity
plan Disaster Recovery regions lessons
are learned emergency response protocols
Dr Goodall the permanent secretary to
the Welsh government from whom we heard
yesterday and today
acknowledged that
insofar as those measures purported to
reduce the risk of disruption events
were whilst Worthy on their own
in their own terms
they did not actually reflect reflect
the reality
of the position on the ground insofar as
although there were a multitude of plans
civil contingency Public Health
Emergency
pandemic influenza plans they had not
been updated and in the majority had not
been updated since 2014.
the disaster recovery Arrangements
were undermined by the fact that
a significant number of recommendations
from earlier exercises had not been
implemented
lessons had not been fully learned from
disruption events
and emergency response protocols
whilst the subject of some training and
exercising and had not been scrutinized
to the full
would you agree therefore that insofar
as the Welsh government sought to
properly understand the risk of pandemic
influenza it it went awry
by virtue of relying upon mitigation
measures which turned out
not to be highly accurate
well as far as the two documents that
I've just seen are concerned I think Dr
Goodall is a more effective witness than
I can be ministers are not responsible
for the corporate risk register
I would expect it to be used by senior
officials to draw the attention of
ministers to areas where senior
officials believe ministerial
intervention would be necessary but
ministers do not routinely
see and are certainly not uh directly
responsible for the material that lies
behind them so Dr Goodall's evidence to
you would be more useful to you I think
than my own all right
could you give us then some indication
of the frequency with which
the issue of the the tier one risk of a
pandemic influenza was brought the
specific attention of the first minister
you were as first Minister ex-officio
the chair of the Welsh the Wales
resilience forum
and it's obvious that there are a number
of Welsh government documents in place
but how often
was pandemic preparedness brought to you
specifically as a as a priority worthy
of your attention
I wonder if I could just make one
General uh Pleasant which is that I have
struggled a little
in Reading documents again for today to
distinguish between things which I am
learning as a result of preparation and
things that I actually knew at the time
and I do not want to imply to you
because I know things now I necessarily
knew them then
so that is a line that I've not always
found it easy to completely walk down
but I think I should probably say that
of course by the time I become first
Minister I have been as you have said
engage in the Welsh government for well
since the very start of devolution and
have lived through a whole series of
people emergencies
and having been the health Minister
particularly I am maybe more alert to
the risk of an influenza pandemic than I
otherwise would have been uh so I am
because of those emergencies that you
had to deal with yeah the the the
history of being in the Welsh government
is constantly dealing with uh one sort
of Civic emergency or another during the
time that I was of a health Minister for
example as well as the measles uh
epidemic I was dealing with officials
with a TB outbreak in the town of fanati
the Ebola outbreak happened while I was
the health Minister and that is you know
completely Beyond things like uh
flooding cultip safety cyber security
incidents and all the other emergencies
that you have to get drawn into by the
time I became first Minister I was
therefore aware but I think as much
because of the background of the fact
that there was a tier one uh risk and
the pandemic influenza was and had been
over many years repeatedly identified as
the most likely risk to face the United
Kingdom
in his witness statement to this inquiry
Mr gething says said
as far as he could recall preparedness
was not a particular focus of Interest
or concern in the government the senate
or outside but he became aware of it by
virtue of his personal involvement in
exercise cygnus
regardless of your own
plainly established personal involvement
as first minister in the field of civil
emergencies and including Health
emergencies
can you recall to what extent the civil
servants brought to you or to your
fellow ministers concerns about the
state of preparedness for pandemic
influenza
well in my uh recollection it would
almost always have been in the context
of exercises that were carried out so
the 2014 cygnus exercise happened when I
was the health minister
uh that was across the Welsh only
exercise
so while uh I share the same identical
experience as uh Mr getting I I don't
think I was ever asked a single question
on the floor of the senate or in any
media interview on preparedness per se
that did not mean that when exercises
took place and conclusions were being
drawn from them that your attention as a
minister was not drawn to them
in your witness statement for this
inquiry you say I became first minister
in 2018 that's obviously December 18. I
do not recall any advice from officials
that there were reservations about the
state of wales's pandemic preparedness
nor did I recall any concerns in the
Senate being raised with me
may we take it from that that none of
the issues that we've so far debated
that civil contingencies report of 2012
the issues about putting the
recommendations from that into place or
As You rightly observe the outcome of
exercise cygnus the whale specific part
of it in 2014 or the UK part of it in
2016 or exercise
and the name has now completely escaped
me tally
acid Italian I'm very grateful strayford
none of those specific issues
we may take it we're brought to your
attention
because they all preceded of course you
becoming first Minister and and if
you never receive advice or you can't
recall advice about reservations in the
state of pandemic preparedness it must
follow that none of those specific
matters were brought to your attention
not to the point that I became first
minister
but as I tried to indicate
I would have been aware of them having
been involved in those events throughout
throughout that period
but your own personal knowledge
of the State of Affairs or the state of
play or the Civil contingency system
can't be translated into executive
action on the part of the government or
a determined attempt to try to improve
the position that's not within your
capability is it
you may have known of problems or flaws
in the system but unless the government
around you identifies those flaws and
determines it will act upon them
nothing is likely to be done is it
so just to try and make myself plainer
if I can
uh by the time I become first Minister I
am not unaware of the issues that have
been faced by the Welsh government or
the exercise in which the watch
government has been involved
but I become a first Minister I do not
receive advice from the Civil Service
that says you need to be particularly
aware of difficulties that we are now
experiencing in these fields
thank you
um
we have heard something of task and
finish committees being instituted in
order to ensure that recommendations
from exercises and and outbreaks are
learned
following swine flu the the Wales
resilience partnership team
agreed to set up the Wales pandemic flu
task and Finnish group to consider
recommendations from the 2009 swine flu
pandemic were you aware that that
committee was unable to finish its task
because the recommendations were not all
fully implemented
I could not say that I was I recollect
being aware of that specific issues
there was a review in 2013 called the
Pollock review which investigated
ironically why lessons weren't being
learned
and as a result of that review
[Music]
the Wales Learning and Development Group
was formed and a decision was taken to
apply something called Joint
organizational learning strategy
but then exercise cygnus came along but
in 14 and 16. and the wells resilience
partnership team delegated
the responsibility of implementing
recommendations to yet another body the
wells pandemic flew preparedness group
that group met
in September 2017.
but didn't meet again after January 18.
were you aware when you became first
minister in December 18 that that
primary group for the implementation of
the recommendations some sickness
while sitting in September 17 never sat
after January 18.
I'd want to uh
check my own recollection but I actually
believe it met him as late as October of
that year
October 18 18. yes I believe that was
the final meeting before its resources
were directed into the No Deal uh brexit
exercise rather than the January all
right well we'll double check that of
course
but the point remains doesn't it that
the work streams which were identified
after exercise cygnus in 2016 were not
all fully implemented because the body
designed to ensure implementation the
wells pandemic flu preparedness group
didn't sit
will agree to disagree whether it was
January or after January or October 18
because of the impact of the new deal
EU exit planning
yes I I think the expert report that the
committee that the inquiry has says that
devolved administrations did pursue
pandemic repairedness and that in Wales
it went on for two years
after the cygnus conclusions were
reached but you reach a point at which
we are diverting resources across the
whole of the Welsh government into
dealing with the dangers that are
sitting right in front of us of leaving
the European Union without a deal
but obviously this inquiry is concerned
exclusively with civil contingency
emergency preparedness from that
standpoint those recommendations were
never fully implemented
that is uh without
doubt I I simply make the point that
government is never exclusively
concerned with any one strand in the
many challenges that it has in front of
it indeed you can't understand the way
the government responds
uh unless you are a way of a context
within which it is responding
pandemic preparedness
is self-evidently a matter of life and
death
is it not yes
to what extent was that
terrible balance
identified between focusing upon the
life and death consequences of pandemic
preparedness and the consequences of
failing to prepare for a new deal EU
exit
apologies if this answer is slightly
longer than some of the ones I've tried
to give so at the point when the UK
government decides to Institute
operation yellowhammer and we are now
facing the reality of leaving the
European Union without a deal with all
the consequences that they would have
had for Wales
I am making a decision along with my
colleagues
to divert resources to deal with that
the number of people we have in the
Welsh government who have genuine
expertise in civil contingency matters
is relatively modest and their skills
are particularly relevant to preparing
for leaving the European Union without a
deal to give you just one example uh
Wales has reservoirs
that serve not simply the Welsh
population for the whole of Birmingham
and the whole of the northwest of
England
chemicals that you rely on to make that
water safe to drink come from Germany
and while we were a member of the
European Union they came without
hindrance and they came on a as they
were needed basis
we faced a real risk that we left the
European Union without a deal
that water supply would no longer be
usable
that is the sort of present danger that
you are talking about it is absolutely
real would be immediate and would have
absolutely direct results in the lives
of people who do we look to in the Welsh
government to help us to find a way
through that if we need to well some of
those people would need to be people who
had the expertise in preparing and
thinking about and indeed in the watch
context practically responding to the
other emergencies we had already faced
to what extent was that balance brought
your attention Mr jayfield and and the
point that you make is is if I may say
so very well made you were faced with
present and immediate risks which of
course you had to address
but it's in the way of government isn't
it that you get on with addressing the
job in hand
and to what extent were you aware that
that necessarily was diverting resources
away from other less present but perhaps
more catastrophic risks was it an issue
on which they sought your advice I I am
very consciously aware of it and I am
consistently aware of it because I'm
forever having to disappoint my
colleagues who have Ambitions in their
own portfolio areas pieces of
legislation that they are committed to
Bringing forward for example and my job
is to explain to them why that will now
not be possible and I do that you know
month after month throughout the whole
of 2019 always to their disappointment
so yes the diversion of resources from
other priorities to dealing with leaving
the European Union without without an
agreement it's a very conscious set of
decisions and constantly debated as well
as to whether we are getting that
balance right
maybe take it from that answer Mr
Drakeford that you were there you were
therefore aware
of the consequential impact upon
pandemic preparedness because of the
necessary diversion of resources that it
was an area that was brought your
attention
and in relation to which you were forced
into the
the
um well Hobson's choice perhaps of
saying
that area can no longer be resourced and
it simply cannot be the subject of focus
because of this other greater risk that
we face well it cannot be a resource to
the extent that it previously was being
resourced it's not the case that you rob
uh everything away from it work does
continue even Beyond uh the end of
December 2018 but you've had to reduce
the resource in order to deal with
something that is immediate and pressing
and potentially catastrophic in its
impact if you're not able to deal with
it
time because obviously we need a break
it's a very convenient point we're
determined to complete your evidence
today Mr Drakeford don't don't panic
um so
um I shall return at 10 past two just
five minute break all rise
[Applause]